I was packing in the Poconos.
We live more.
We're now and the great boss and the
dynamic duo of pride fighting
championships back in the day,
classic fights.
You guys are attached to some of the
greatest fights of all time.
We are used to tell him every time a
single fight to say because at the time
were 6 billion people.
I go,
hey,
understand too.
In 6 billion people just did the
government dating for this show because
we love that shows at all to this man.
Mr.
Rogen,
Bas rutten in many ways saved my life.
Oh,
it's getting dark early.
Yeah,
I thought we're going to go down a half.
Nope.
Mara,
when Allah wants immediately go down to
a bus route and saved my life.
No,
no,
no.
Let's keep it positive because,
uh,
my two worlds collided on my very first
event in pride at Bushido.
One October fifth,
2003,
a pro wrestler dose Scottish junior
member of the guy in the mask and the
act to.
They have to actually cut out even
bigger.
I to Vegas Fighting Miracle Cro,
cop one.
And can you imagine a mission in North
America would never allow that and yet
went in.
Boom.
Did you see the recent one with Gary
Garcia?
The rising English Kennedy.
I just saw like,
you know,
like,
like a,
like a repeat thing,
like a little loop thing.
But she fought and I don't know,
I don't know if she was sitting to
Bressler whatever she was.
She was hobbled.
She couldn't walk.
Her knees were totally wrapped up.
She was limping from the moment she got
in there.
This scanning Garcia's towering over
this old lady.
She just beats.
She swallowed it.
I mean it was just a giant Silva taking
a two by four against Takeshi Secura.
Remember big giant Silva two by four.
It was like hit him with at the end of
the.
The angle.
Yeah.
On the pride fighting championship
event.
Why did he do that?
It was,
uh,
again,
the,
the marriage of pro wrestling and,
and pride in many ways the,
the larger than life storylines and
production could lead to things like
that.
And we sought firsthand the freak fights
if you.
It wasn't,
I mean it wasn't a part of the actual
fight.
The fight itself was there,
but you remember allister used to bring
the,
the.
There were pro wrestling esque
entrances,
which.
Right,
but a lot of people loved.
But was this a part of his entrance?
This was finding somebody?
Yeah,
this was after the fight.
We remember Takeshi cigarette in giant
silver right there,
and it was like,
yeah,
he had the Dubai for choreographed.
It was,
I think it was.
It was maybe a part of the presentation
and not something that,
like you say,
he wanted to assault someone with a few
fights for in the early days that you
were like,
oh,
okay.
That's a fixed fight,
right?
There's a few.
Oh Alicia,
did you
remember it?
It was the funniest thing ever.
A Coleman was fighting to Catia.
Yeah.
They told me there was going to be a.
He was going to get finished at six
minutes by way of heel hook,
so now the press comes to me and he
tells me what do you think's going to
happen in his fight,
and so it's easy to go.
Who's going to win six minutes?
He'll hook.
Everybody froze because this was before
the fight.
So they had to change their whole
gimmick.
What they were going to do.
I went to one and a half minutes now,
but I just thought you future pride
result.
They had it all planned out.
They hold up,
uh,
you know,
everything with Takata would say,
well actually I can extend those course.
Yeah,
that was.
that was 100 percent that,
you know,
Takata came into our studio training at
the Beverly Hills Jujitsu Club.
We had white and blue belts a tapping
him.
So it was not like this guy was.
Well,
he was just an old time dance.
Yes.
They wanted to.
Again,
that's,
you know,
you talk about how pride fighting
championships at Genesys,
it was that,
you know,
bringing the biggest,
the so-called toughest best pro wrestler
against Hixon Gracie,
the,
the mythic,
a falling Tuto Jujitsu fighter.
The UFC had a similar but more rational
approach to it recently with cm punk
versus making gall.
He said,
well,
we'll give this cm punk guy a kid with
one fight,
one amateur fight.
I think he had at least one amateur
fight and one fight in the UFC show.
It's promise choked guy out.
And we said,
okay,
you're going to get a tough kit.
You're gonna get a tough kid,
but [inaudible] going to have to fight a
real fighter,
but you know,
you're not going to fight Hixon gracie.
You know what I mean?
It was just at that time,
nobody had Jujitsu like Hickson.
It's just,
he was just so above and beyond
everything.
Yeah.
Unreal.
So will be $400.
No,
no,
that's a nice round number that they
always got to wonder who threw that out
first like they did.
Everyone's such a disservice.
Three 98.
That sounds way more believable than
perfect.
$400.
What's crazy is when you see these tie
fighters who literally do have hundred
fights at 20 years old.
Yeah.
And fight you got instead of sits on
[inaudible] who's a,
the lightweight champion on Gloria.
You in fact,
uh,
many years ago in Canada doing Moitai
on,
uh,
on Tsn,
the espn equivalent up there.
Same thing when you brought in the tie
fighters.
They,
but they were,
as you know,
Joe,
and there's a good documentary,
shameless plug,
showtime.
It's going to be showing a documentary
about a fighting in Thailand.
Didn't moit time where these kids
literally,
that's how they survive,
right?
You start at eight and nine years old
and you're on your way to hopefully
making enough to eat.
Did you get a new documentary that we're
doing right now?
There are people in jail like murderous.
They get a chance to fight themselves
for a pardon.
Oh my.
That's a new show is going to start
looking at weekend.
Maybe the documentary as that Red Devil.
Oh,
what's his name?
The rat suit.
The guy with the horn,
with the horns.
Cut Off.
Famous.
A famous actor talking that actor.
Oh,
he's also into the gang.
God dammit.
He's narrating it Jamie.
You know it is.
The dude is a star of hellboy.
I got the documentary is called five
rounds to freedom as well,
but it's narrated by head.
Pull up,
pull up the page,
the page on it,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
Freedom.
Ron.
You Go,
wow.
That's crazy.
So what are their crimes that they're
going to be one guy that he stabbed
somebody in the neck and I go,
Nigeria,
what petty crime?
I go,
okay,
I can understand it,
but it wouldn't bring.
Criminal State sponsored rehabilitation
program,
popular known as prison fight is not
reserved for petty criminals under the
law.
Violent criminals and crew,
including those convicted of murder.
Hold on a second piece of this is the
one who was convicted of murder and
sexual assault had been freed and in
some cases fully absolved of their
crimes through their participation in
prison fights.
Well,
that sounds crazy,
Arizona.
My birthday.
That's even crazier than that.
Anybody would allow this thought you
have to do if you're a violent criminal
is prove that you're more violent than
the other violent criminals and you get
your freedom.
That's fucking insane.
Yeah.
I don't think there's a lesson to be
learned for them.
Results on one point.
Oh yeah.
Ken,
violent men redeemed themselves through
violent acts.
That's ridiculous.
Of course,
they think probably a pleasant placenta
plus becomes a negative.
Maybe they think that way.
Your sister or your daughter or your mom
and then they get out because they beat
the fuck out of all the other 100
percent agree.
If you see the trailer,
that's what a woman says.
He stabbed his kid in the neck,
killed a kid,
and now his guys going to fight for his
life to get out of there.
You see,
it shouldn't be.
No,
shouldn't be losing.
So,
uh,
back to the $400,
no most likely not the dl number in
anybody's case,
somebody just made that up for
propaganda purposes.
If they would've said over 400 but just
below 400.
See,
but making it for.
And I love that his son is super active
now and I love the crone is fighting
like really top guys now you know,
he's he fuck with Jerry in his last
fight.
It's a tough fucking Chi.
That's a tough area.
I will always wonder what happened to
crossly Gracie.
Remember,
strike.
That's the thing.
He seemed to be the first Gracie to me
to take it to the next level.
Become more well rounded and well versed
and whip.
Done well.
I think Haji showed really great promise
until King Mo knocked him out.
Right.
You know,
that was a big knockout.
King Mo can crack.
We've got some serious power.
He's a tremendous athlete.
Student striking as well.
Huge boxing fan.
I'll never forget that ground and pound
Kale that he had with Seth Pinsky.
Scary guy.
God.
Yeah.
But that the throw the guard to the side
and drop that right hand on you like,
oh my God.
It's a.
well in Henderson.
I
mean it's amazing.
Uh,
some at the time I'm,
you remember,
I mean he just a Ninja that was one shot
and I told him to do to everybody.
He is the guy that when he has a,
you know,
when he has a face as a great striker
and I tell them,
just take them down.
I saw him,
he took me down.
I mean you is freaking animal.
Like in training.
My Focus Mitts and my hands would hurt
after I would hold him and he would
stand on one leg and hit.
I don't have no clue how he generated
that kind of force,
but he had so much power and I said it,
just take him down.
Scott Smith,
why would you even go with them?
The guys is trying to just take them
down,
knock them out on the ground,
and he didn't do it.
Every time at the end of the round,
he did it.
Hit him one time it was almost dazed.
The belt went around again,
but the third run the loader compelling
career for Scott Smith to right.
Hadn't headlining events on CBS major
network exposure.
I remember what we called the Christmas
miracle when he came back and knocked
down calmly and,
and again,
the guy who's I think back working,
uh,
what you know has a steel back in the
factory and you,
it's interesting all the sporting,
such a short period of time.
Of course we've seen the explosion,
but what could have been even in,
in with a,
with a [inaudible].
And we saw what happened with kimball,
but it's just interesting for me now as
we reminisce about stuff,
how,
how so many organizations had
opportunities and yet fell by the
wayside for,
for one reason or another,
a lot of it's self inflicted.
Well,
elitist
c was a really hard one to watch because
it was bastardizing the sport you were
seeing,
they were standing people up like,
do you remember what number that 15
second rule was?
But it was also they were standing up
and dominant positions like Roy Nelson
and Arlovski kind of incredulous working
for Kamora and they stood them up but
like,
whoa,
that's crazy.
But then you can understand why those
Kimbo slice,
you know,
taking what was necessary to bring it
was the first organization to make it to
two major network tv.
And I think there were some decent
fighters along the way as well.
Where you Akimbo fan at all in terms I
know your,
your martial arts and that's why I
respected sit here,
bowing down at the altar of the erudite
one.
But did you like what Kimbo slice
represented at the time?
I think to most sites was a tough guy
and he was a fun guy to watch,
but the reality of what he represented
as a mixed martial arts fighter at that
time was he was,
he was fairly novice.
Yes.
He didn't really have a ground game and
he really couldn't stop a good wrestler
from taking him down,
but he was a good puncher who was really
good in those backyard,
brought in those environments,
you know,
like he was tough for the 99 percent of
the guys out there and he would smash
guys and he smashed a few guys in mma.
Yeah.
And you know what I really respect about
Kimbo said he went on the ultimate
fighter and he gave a go of it can mean
he really does make the.
Yeah,
it was already a huge youtube star at
the time.
So he went on with all these other
unknown unknown guys who are wrestlers
and football players and guys like Roy
Nelson and he handled it like a fucking
man.
Big Target.
That is a big
target on his back.
Everybody knew him.
Everybody wants to fight him.
And the numbers were through the roof
when he was on and he was a great guy.
Yeah,
he was always a super friendly,
real,
real nice guy.
Always cool with everybody up.
Despite his appearance as he looked like
blue,
the gold teeth,
crazy beer and left.
We had so much fun with that guy.
Good guy.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's why though it seems,
because I think there's the argument
continues even now in the sport.
Right?
What with a rankings,
right?
Joe?
How come Damien Maia is not getting the
next shot at you?
Tyron Woodley.
Well,
keep the money.
Fight.
Not fight that Woodley and wonderboy.
Half to read 100 percent draw.
I agree 100 percent,
but then I also think dominick Cruz in
and cody Garbrandt as much as what a
masterpiece.
But if you look at the backgrounds and
what's happened with in the past,
I think dominick Cruz also deserves a
rematch.
I don't agree with that.
I don't agree with that because I don't
think that was that close.
I think cody clearly won that fight.
Green.
One thing.
Cody represents what?
The body of work that he's done in the
shore.
Yeah,
I mean he,
Tj dillashaw,
he was an amazing fighter,
but tj has been waiting for a long time.
Tj barely lost a fight with dominick was
a razor close decision that could've
gone either way and then he goes on to
be half our sun sal and I just feel like
in his position now and then he beat,
you know,
the,
um,
lended Linacre shut her down and that's
when there's no exact science,
I guess is what I'm saying in it comes
to,
to matchmaking and putting together
championship fights and what do you
market the freak,
the star,
the dominant fighter.
That's why I love the sport.
Yeah.
While there's certainly arguments either
way.
I mean there's an interesting triangle
between the three of those guys.
I mean there's a lot of good match ups
that can be made with those guys.
And then also there's Dodson,
you know,
Doug don't ever sleep on Dotson.
Dotson might've lost to Linacre,
but I think Dodson when he's on is one
of the fastest guys in the division just
glued.
I always say,
do the math,
the weight jumps like a freaking spider
almost.
It doesn't slip.
It's really weird.
And if he catches you,
man,
that finishes.
I mean he's a guy hasn't wait.
Thunderbolt.
Yeah,
exactly.
Lighter,
you know,
like say the luck of base camp pop.
Well Cody Garbrandt,
Dotson,
others are showing.
Even Demetrius Johnson seems to have,
again,
pound for pound,
one of the greats.
Right.
One of my favorite fighters ever.
I think he's becoming more,
not necessarily more aggressive,
but there's,
there's some finish now to,
to his game as well.
He's always been trying to show you
guys,
but you know,
you find a guy like Ali back off.
Yes.
You know,
it's a tough fucking guy talked to
finish those guys.
Let me think about who he finished.
He finished Moraga,
finished her Gucci with one second to
go,
you know what I mean?
He's a fucking animals Max out.
Benevidez punch the shit out of pseudo
stops one route.
That's where really I was like,
wow,
this uh,
you know,
it's.
But that's,
I'm hoping like we've seen with boxing,
but uh,
the,
the UFC fan base mma fan base begins to
rally around these lighter weight
classes because to me that's a,
that's mixed martial arts,
uh,
at its best.
I always want the WEC,
that wasn't my favorite show because
these guys had full gas tanks.
Now nowadays everybody has it.
But at the time were only the
lightweights,
and that's why I love that show.
And then when you see butted up like,
hey,
more power to them.
Actually.
Fair,
smart.
I think cody garbrandt has a real
possibility.
Becoming a huge mainstream star was a
handsome guy.
He's a devastating puncher.
Amen.
Vicious striker.
He's charismatic,
he's confident,
he's very,
he's very moral and ethical.
You know,
it.
A relationship with that young boy that
had leukemia and to help them through
it.
And I mean,
it's like intense,
intense shit man.
I mean,
he's a special guy and that was,
it wasn't leukemia is.
I mean,
he's a special guy.
Stop Shop,
man.
I,
like I said,
we just mentioned the podcast.
It's like,
um,
it was almost like he was holding back
and he said,
okay,
I'm going to pull it out.
Once I've fought fight for the title,
that's when I really got to show what I
can do because he looked like a
completely different fighter.
He was always good,
but this was a whole.
But the way he dominated dominick Cruz
mentally especially leading up to the
fight where it appeared that he had
gotten,
you know,
Cruz had gotten under his skin when he
stormed out of the interview,
done.
But from the opening bell,
like you say,
the,
the taunting and stuff,
and yet able to back it up and,
and show whether it's evolution or
whether it was already there.
A masterful performance man grew up in
tough environments.
And I think that what he said after the
fight,
when I asked him about it,
like,
what does the taunting that didn't
bother you?
No,
I love that stuff.
It's like I'm used to that.
Like,
you know,
that was one where he's comfortable in.
Well,
he was also able to stay real calm in
that world championship spotlight that's
very,
very mature.
Plus you flipped it around,
you know,
he,
he shows crews that he doesn't want to
go into this battle,
almost like walking off.
But then once the fight started,
he started doing it to Cruz and I think
it got to curse,
you know,
pointing at the ground,
doing the little dance moves.
Guts,
credit,
cruise for the way he handled the.
Yeah.
But man,
like a man not as good as anybody.
Tim Kennedy's another one handled it as
good as anybody.
Yeah.
Some guys handled it.
Mcgregor handled as good as anybody.
He beat me.
That's it.
Know that's a,
that's as,
as admirable,
you know,
as I'm putting out the correct game plan
and winning.
You know what I mean?
There's something incredibly admirable
about a guy who can take a loss like a
man or a woman,
you know?
I mean anyone who can just accept what
happened and that's just what it is.
You know?
It's a very unfortunate when you see
someone that's saying some things that
don't really make sense like after a
fight or blaming on other people or
blaming it on their camp or blaming it
on an injury and it's just an I,
I think you,
you did bring this up and I agree with
you in terms of when someone has been
knocked out or someone has been in a a
very grueling,
tough fight.
I don't know why we are forced to
interview them
myself to at times where I'm like,
that's not right.
I remember
interviewed Cro Cop after the Gonzaga
fight when a Gonzaga head kicked him and
he.
I was asking him questions.
He had no idea where he was.
You could tell there was no one home.
I mean he had just gotten completely
flat lined and I'd said to them then I
said,
I don't,
I really don't think we should interview
people after knockout again,
but I dropped it.
We never talked about it again.
And then after that one and I was like,
that doesn't make any sense.
So he was out cold and I'm
like you said Alex,
obviously to where he has,
you know,
for whatever reason,
thought what he did is he had a good.
Yeah,
he really didn't,
not really close,
but I.
Yeah.
And that's,
you know,
to uh,
unfortunate that I don't see what it
accomplished says anyway.
Yeah.
It didn't make me feel bad too and I got
to give them the opportunity and then I
had to give them an opportunity again
because you couldn't see it for the
first time.
So we had to watch it from another
angle.
The other angle reveal that it didn't
happen.
So it was kind of stuck,
you know,
that's not fair.
It's not done,
but it's also not fair.
If someone tells you they had a good
team,
you got to
Whoa,
100,
whatever.
The fuck
crazy.
We saw that he had the gifts and we saw
Steve,
Hey,
do this.
And we went,
oh no.
What about the bat?
My introduction to probably my very
first show,
Bushido one,
our first fight,
Chris Brennan,
Asian Woods,
Woca.
I'm settling in,
getting ready.
I'm really excited working with boss.
And immediately there's controversy.
I'm Brendan had to in the arm bar,
we saw him tap and right away the
referee go,
wait,
what's happening?
They,
they actually restarted the fight and
seconds later Brendan submits them with
the Camorra.
So right off the bat,
a double submission.
The Christian.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I always a lot of great.
How's he doing right now?
Did you hear it?
I haven't talked to
tune in a while.
Last I saw him was at a UFC a couple of
years back.
He said Hi.
And I know he was teaching them
Dallas,
I think on social media.
Every so often I see him.
I think he's very successful instructor
right now.
He's a very good Jujitsu instructor on
top of being a very good fighter.
Yeah.
No,
no,
that was A.
Yeah.
Well,
it's so many.
So many memories,
man.
Second rob all the way back.
Old Doc double a double tap on,
borrowed against us.
Coordinate and Marilla.
Busta Montay.
Even our good friend John said that that
was the biggest.
You know,
he owned up to it too,
but that,
you know,
the guy doesn't make many mistakes,
but that one I didn't know that he in
the book regretted a greatly obviously.
So.
But uh,
but yeah.
Sorry.
You were saying marilla.
Bustamante yeah.
In the UFC against God dammit.
How the fuck am I not from team quest?
Yes.
We just talked about that the other day.
Yup.
Yeah,
he got Matt Lindland an arm bar.
Matt
millen tapped.
He said he didn't tap.
They restarted again
and then he got him in to get to you in
the next round.
Exactly.
On top of the world,
man.
Well,
it was such a great rivalry to backup
private btt and um,
and the shooter box man,
it was to the point where they get old
even walking by each other like,
okay,
wait a minute.
What's going on here?
Let's say it was so,
uh,
intense,
very intense rivalry which made for
some,
uh,
you know,
legendary matchups when we're talking
about the way here.
It was giant.
I mean,
you,
will,
you guys,
you guys represented like this wild
west.
No,
it was just,
it was,
everything was crazy,
you know,
that's the thing,
because there were also at the time,
these were the best bet,
but you're white whiting was also the
mix of the what we already talked about,
but we were talking on the way here.
Mauricio Shogun Hua.
Remember 2:23
years old goes through Quentin rampage,
Jackson,
Antonio.
Whoa.
Jerry Nogueira,
one of the best fights in pride history
and then in one night Alistair overeem
and record to win that Grand Prix.
And you don't say what Jon Jones did at
23.
God bless them,
man.
One of the best.
But Mauricio Shogun Hua beast at that
age,
man.
Oh yeah.
I mean there was a lot of guys and it's
almost like I would have loved to have
seen what Nogueira in his prime would
have been able to do in the UFC and I
would've loved to seen what fate or in
his prime because essentially when
Nogueira fought fader door,
he was in his prime.
Yes.
I mean it was that pre or post Bob Sapp.
That was after.
After he fought a sap at the national
stadium.
But the problem with that is anything
post Bob Sapp,
you have to take into consideration how
much damage he took Bob's hats because
he got beat the fuck that was dropped on
his head due to compensating.
I go,
hey,
we got this first death right,
was like optum headfirst and nice.
Three hundred and 50 pounds.
It's similar with the monster plex,
right?
Our dearly departed friend,
Kevin Randleman.
When fresh off of upsetting miracle
puppy goes and drops off fatal.
And again,
fader,
a million Neko let you say would have
been very good to see what we had done
in his prime because even despite being
dropped on his head,
calmly coolly regrouped and then submit
randleman with the memorial about a
minute and a half later.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
Yeah.
Fatal Aurion is prime.
She's the one thing that was.
I mean it's actually just interesting.
It's cool to see those old videos and
wash those old fights.
But there's something about like epic
matchups between great fighters,
like did the opportunity of Cain
Velasquez in his prime versus fade or in
his prime.
I would have loved to see.
That would have been so for all these
injuries.
I would have loved to see that.
Yup.
Yeah.
Who did it?
Well,
we didn't get to see miracle one fader,
which at the time,
I mean that was the most anticipated
heavyweight fight in MMA history.
Most amazing about that fight is fatal
and beat him standing.
That's why we.
Exactly.
He is the one
that adapted and beat miracle.
What his most potent weapon.
He's this guy that he.
His striking,
it looks not technical,
but when he strikes it's perfect.
There's no load up whatsoever.
He holds his fistdale and from here it
goes forward.
You can tell when he shot is accurate.
Is a member of the entry cost,
but with Antonio Gigolo guarantee you
the final.
The tournament.
But yeah,
the way he would enter the garden.
I think that's what Fabrizio Verdon did
this homework,
because remember they're doom almost
bay.
Well he did.
He baited him when,
when he submitted them and I think doom
Shaka fight also right when it goes soka
fought fader,
a timer,
the rematch and pride.
Right?
That he was throwing these bombs and I'm
doing the commentating.
I said,
well,
he's really overcommitting.
He should watch out.
He doesn't fall into a triangle choke.
And then they brought that piece and it
put it next to the piece.
Whitey Ford for doom you.
That's exactly what happened.
He was over committing and right away
they slept on that triangle to,
against tk though was ridiculous,
right?
The elbows.
Uh,
it was a rings though.
There was a.
That was an egregious error.
It should not have been.
I don't remember that.
Yeah.
The,
that's why it should've.
It should've been a victory for us
there.
No elbows.
A lot of the grads.
The man,
when I think back now,
the rule,
I just,
it seemed like there was no real rule,
no ground and pound.
Yes.
And they also,
again,
it was,
there was,
you know,
came from old wrestling and then into
the rings you could hit to the body on
the ground.
Is that how it works?
Clue.
They,
uh,
feel like you couldn't hit to the
ground.
Weird rule on a promotion that
introduced people to two people like
fate or Antonio,
Rodrigo Nogueira,
Dan Henderson.
I mean,
they all go babaloo.
Sobrato rings,
uh,
produced a whole bunch of man.
It was,
I wish would have been nice to have
over.
Our friend joined us for some of those
fights.
I should have definitely made a trip
over there just to watch,
you know,
because I was thinking of flying to see
fade or fight against material man to
ever make it over there.
Oh No.
Not this life,
but I just,
I feel like that's one of the things
that I probably should have saw it pride
in its prime.
I always tell people out 90,000
seats.
I remember Dana,
he came for the first time,
but it was the first row.
And I remember when I look back,
when the opening started,
I looked back at east with his mouth
open.
He looks around to go.
This is the craziest things.
Parents.
I remember looking at him.
I go,
right,
this is crazy.
I mean,
it was insane.
He brought chuck.
You remember drover and Quinton rampage.
Jackson five.
Um,
the but okay,
well there you go though the,
the,
the UFC used to have the ramp and the
elaborate entrances and I know they
wanted to separate from my other light
of employment,
wwe and the wrestling aspect,
but don't know Bella toward does a
pretty decent job when their entrances
and stuff.
Do you think that that is something that
could help UFC now or is it or is it you
like the boxing entrance that's pure,
you know,
the sport aspect of it.
Because I think fans in Japan,
man,
I mean the production values were
ridiculous and I think it was,
it added to the experience while it's
definitely a different thing,
whether or not it's better.
I don't know,
man.
I just like this,
uh,
past UFC with Ronda Rousey and Amanda
Nunez walking down the tunnel that I
like just watching weather all those
guys.
Yeah,
I agree.
Give a fuck about fireworks.
I'm not a little kid.
Yeah,
I want,
I want to see what someone's face looks
like.
They're about to go to war.
You know,
when I went and watched the you,
she,
most of the time,
you know,
it's recorded.
I turned my phone off and that's where I
go fast forward.
I go to the fights to pick something up.
When you then had to go like,
oh man,
that was like,
I got,
let's take a look at that.
Do you know?
So I'm a little bit of idea,
but that's how it shows you how much I
wonder in joy it Yoda,
the video footage that they had,
the pride fighting championships and
especially the one would feed or woke up
crying.
That was a tree was amazing for sure.
Like movie trailers for the fight.
They'd show you the tea that the movie
trailer and they were not allowed to
show it to the American audience for
some reason to add this.
I don't know why they weren't allowed to
show the movie trailer part of it.
Nope.
That was,
that was Tokyo TV or wherever.
Whoever had that contract,
food,
GTV,
GTV and they get like 5 million bucks to
show what was always weird for us when
you're shows would either be like 4:00
in the morning,
so we'd have.
I'd have guys over my house at 4:00
in the morning.
Everybody be drinking red bull,
trying to stay awake and then pride
would come on.
Or you guys would have the fights and
then it would air on tv a while later.
Like later.
Yeah.
I tried to break it.
I was calling all the windows and you
know,
to see what gambling if we could do
something with that.
But no,
it didn't.
Cubs win the world series and.
But everybody knew the results,
you know,
because of all the websites.
So you just watched to see what
happened.
I combat sports is the one.
Forget football,
baseball,
hockey,
everything else.
I don't care if I know the result,
I will watch a fight.
Yeah.
If I know the result,
I'll watch a fight too.
It's just,
I think it's the,
it's not as good.
Meryl Streep?
No,
it's not as good,
but it's still.
I don't know.
There's something maybe because it's
more digestible size,
but I just,
I find fighting to be something,
you know,
I,
I will watch other than if I record a,
a hockey game and I know the score will
and screw it.
I'm not watching it.
Yeah,
man.
I was reading some of the responses to
Metal Meryl Streep.
She's crying,
just blasted for Olympic sports.
That's what I said.
Okay.
What the comedian what,
what in what context do you think she.
My knee jerk reaction.
Same thing.
Hey,
love me some murals street,
but why do you have to trash at my
mayor?
I'm wondering if she didn't even ever
know what mixed martial arts was.
Someone gave her the word with arts in
it and she made the time.
Well,
it's not even arts,
but if football doesn't say football
arts.
Right.
So let's see.
Went after mixed martial arts because
she said the word arts and then she
ripped it.
Your right.
She said,
which by the way is not.
They are like,
okay,
well what?
What Arts,
you know,
it's not the art of pretending you're
right.
It's the art of execution under extreme
circumstances.
Very difficult circumstances,
highly trained opponent,
trying to smash bones in your face.
Incredibly difficult to do advantage
Rogan,
right?
It's artistic.
You can't tell me.
When Anderson Silva landed that front
kick to veto Belfort's face and you see
his legs given that's art,
that's art.
What about Joan and on Anderson Silva or
Hook right into the heel hook.
That was incredible.
That was like a movie scene,
man.
Brazilian Jujitsu is art.
A brutal piece of art.
When Quentin,
rampage Jackson Queer Carto Rona Slam.
Oh my God,
he arches backwards.
Oh my God.
It didn't.
Someone actually call that shot a few
seconds before you saw it coming.
Believed in Christ to hold onto that
yet,
hold on gotTa,
let go of that fucking thing.
But then the replay.
Don't.
You did see this smash heads.
He goes,
well,
but your wife,
why did he hold on?
Who's probably gone anyway?
And even if the young smash heads up,
the,
uh,
the impact was so brutal there a Ronan
was essentially never the same again.
No,
no,
we never really fought well again after
that fight.
And it was so much potential.
But you know what's funny,
we're talking again.
Paolo filio another gun.
Oh,
he went crazy though.
Did you see God?
Good Garden.
Was Sassy the evolution of him or what
he's now doing right now,
he's at the door of the top guys in
[inaudible] 85.
I like it.
I need to say about a role now because I
was interviewing a rohde and he had a
cup of tea.
Japanese green tea was standing here as
somebody and it was so cool that he kept
his cool.
So good,
pushed the thing,
fell off and he's sitting and he does
this and he comes up here at the cuff.
He grabbed this school because I know it
is going to go.
Just
not looking good.
And he brings it back up and he sets it
down.
Man Jitsu Stud as was Paula Filio yeah.
Paula was one of those guys.
He got you on the ground,
man.
He was a fucking pitch.
You'll do you remember?
Uh,
will you just call it a fight?
We started the radio and Louisa,
for me,
uh,
in Bushido want to say it was an to me
the earliest example for me and probably
one of the best grappling fights I'd
ever seen in an mma arena member,
Ricardo Arona and dean lister and their
rematch from the Abu Dhabi and we were
pumping the crap out of it.
It wasn't,
uh,
wasn't the most fan friendly friend.
Hey,
let me ask you guys about this cobalt on
my mind because I'm tired of talking.
Thinking about grappling matches,
what did you guys think about Aoki?
How are you?
Okay.
He used to wear those tights and uh,
you know,
when he went to fight in us,
they wouldn't let him wear the tights.
Eddie Bravo and I have talked about this
a million,
like
I don't see a problem with him wearing
the tights.
Like why does he get the sweat?
It has more traction.
But girls can wear like rash guard tops.
Right?
Can they cover their arms?
Can girls cover their arms?
I don't know.
No,
they should not be allowed to do that.
I don't wonder why.
Okay.
So why do you think he should have been
allowed to have fun?
But yeah,
when I watched Aoki fighting got to rap
dudes up.
But it's crazy legs.
The tax,
the tax man.
George Grid gels.
ACL.
Yes.
I'll go roll on your knees.
You Yoakim Hanson.
You wish you Manson when the walk off.
There's another guy that I wonder why it
never came to the UFC when he apparently
didn't want like,
you know when the UFC bought pride,
they had the contracts.
He apparently didn't want to come over.
Right.
He also has been a ton of war man.
And you know,
he's,
I think he just fought again.
That's what I read.
Or retired by boy from Norway,
right?
Maybe in Europe.
But remember what he was.
He was powerful.
I remember he was one of the few guys
that can actually hurt you from a back
position.
So one guy,
a Russian one time who knocked somebody
out to a,
mounted him,
really laid on his back and he a big
swing and he wins the fight.
He knocks the guy out.
The guy had mounted him event where it
said that Duane Ludwig broke his orbital
bone when Dwayne was on his back.
Dwayne swung up and crack even the
eyeball and broke his little hole from
the bottom.
That which he did the coolest thing.
What I always wanted to do.
When did you know at the Bartow?
Yeah,
I think that's important stance on one
leg and then go do that.
I'm telling my students about this,
that you can do this,
but never did it.
Right.
That's an old man.
He was a part he and train a little bit
with me as well and actually had that
great fight on seeing here.
Let's see it here.
There you go.
Beautiful.
Even with talented,
his first fight in pride against uh,
uh,
keep Henson.
We've talked about a split decision,
but buddy that show a joe to me maybe.
I mean pride had so many legendary cards
as well,
but everyone always asked me who I want
to get into pride fighting
championships.
What do I watch a lot?
I always tell them to start with Bushido
nine,
the tournament where you had one where
that fight.
Well,
the fight with a Hanson and uh,
um,
we just talked about it.
Edwards,
but hobbled.
Go me to fight of the year candidates
and one night against Louise Azeredo and
touch with your copper jewelry,
Dan Henderson,
Gono and shown in tremendous night of
fights,
bro.
Yeah.
Then those are some of the ones that
kind of get lost or forgotten about
making ensign anyway,
or which who I mentioned because I have
a funny story with Anson.
I bet you he challenged him.
Mara.
Challenge Enzo.
Let's.
Hey,
let's re.
Let's rewind that.
Shall We?
Oh my God.
Mr.
Mark Coleman and uh,
Kevin Randleman.
We were in a Boston hotel room.
Uh,
this is after pride event.
We don't know which one and a pride back
then.
Love to party.
Loved to experiment like,
you know,
and I'm a good humble,
uh,
innocent Canadian boy who hadn't really
gotten out much joe and palate.
When we say experiment,
we talked about like my kind and similar
to the buses are more.
Have you ever taken a percocet?
I'm like,
what?
And he's like,
have you ever taken a percocet?
So I of course look at it up or pink
color.
How would I want to know what I'm not
interface.
Come on,
you've got to try it.
I said,
okay,
well why not?
So he gives me,
you gave me three percosets do not one,
three.
So I take these things.
Okay,
fine.
Just whatever coleman and randleman walk
in and uh,
all of a sudden,
you know,
I'm,
I'm still,
I'm not feeling a negative.
Oh me,
I'm very impatient.
I'm like,
well,
what the Hell is not working?
It's not working.
Randleman asked boss.
He goes,
what do you give them in Bosco?
I gave them three percocet.
You did well,
and then all of a sudden almost on cue
it hits me and I ended up,
uh,
incident anyway,
was there a with us as well visiting and
I ended up,
for some reason going into my old,
a pro wrestling manager.
He'll mode and going right up to incent
and go,
hey,
I think I can take you bro.
I think I can take.
And I'm doing this again.
I'm really just kind of needling him and
he,
he's trying to be nice.
He knows,
okay,
this is the English announcer,
cool.
Whatever.
But I am pushing it because I'm,
I'm impacted by percosets by.
But do you,
are you thinking that you're doing a
performance?
No,
that's,
that's the thing.
I,
I felt like I was,
I was hot.
I was,
I was like,
I was out of my mind.
I thought you were going to eat up
insane anyway.
I don't think I could beat him up,
beat him up,
Joe.
But I challenged him a fight.
He finally had enough faith in me,
broke my glasses and I got a bloody nose
and I'm like,
well,
now I've got to wear the badge of honor.
And I took the picture with him and uh,
an ensign and I'm like,
yeah,
I don't think I'll be doing percosets
anymore.
I'll stick to that.
The only time they're trained killers.
Yes.
Thank you.
And never get it.
Thanks to the good guy.
Really good guy.
He hit the ground.
He's not gonna.
Do you remember when last?
Randy couture?
Yes.
And He,
uh,
he was one of the first guys I ever saw
through a really hard kicks to the legs
from his guard.
And I remember watching that going,
oh,
look at this,
because he would prop himself up on his
back on me,
whip that leg into it.
And he hit randy with some hard kicks
back boy,
my boy frank shamrock Tomlinson and new
way.
A lesson at the rampage when his
brother.
What sentence?
Brothers and the Egan.
Egan.
Oh yeah,
there were because of what frank did.
And speaking of brawls,
how bout a coleman and Maricio Shogun
Hua?
When,
uh,
who,
went to post,
broke his arm and shoot a saint house.
Phil filled Beverly Silva.
Stepping on.
Phil Baroni said pride was wild,
Bro.
It was amazing.
You guys had like real street or in the
back?
Oh yeah.
Well that just walking into the place,
high ingrained.
She decides out of the blue.
I have no cool way to pull the fire
alarm.
This is before the whole show stopped.
And buddy the extinguisher fell like a
colored extinguished coggin coming and
he's screaming.
Yeah.
Everything falls out of the freaking
ceiling.
Fire retardant,
he released it,
he released in the sky and the show went
on.
Anyway,
he's just walking and suddenly he
separates himself from the group and he
hits them and you don't fight that
night.
What's?
Yeah,
that was the first time when he said,
well,
the sheet was the first time five
members of the Gracie family had ever
competed on the St Cordova.
Daniel by marriage.
Right.
So you had,
you had hedsel and Carlos.
Nancy had Henzel highend whoa.
Dorrigo.
Daniel.
And who was the other one?
I'm missing disrespect,
but the Daniel thing is a weird one.
Is that your last name?
Where's it your wife's last name?
What in the fuck is going on here,
sir?
And went to a boxing gym one.
I could use the boxing the during,
you know,
to train and the guy comes to me and he
says,
if you want I can teach you some
groundwork.
She,
she didn't want me.
Gracie,
I see your gray.
She is married to a gracie.
Oh,
how strange.
And a button.
But that night high and took the mic
after and went off.
I mean using every expletive known
demand just snapped because of the
controversy and well,
high end was the craziest of all.
And we had some good times with him.
Oh real good time to what?
I eat.
A tortured soul,
but at the toss anyway.
Always a good one of the few.
Not few,
a lot of guys,
but he always went out of his way to
make me.
I mean,
you're a legend,
but to make the announcer feel good,
he always came up more.
Hello,
good to see you.
And well,
once you get old,
uh,
the bounces,
Dallas randleman body,
the very first New Year's Eve we spent
in Japan for shockwave,
it was you,
Kevin Randleman highend gracie winter
because he knew he is the one that made
the most sense.
Was this guy you were the one that kept
the peace because Kevin was,
was losing his mind and even hiring
gracie kept saying,
don't worry,
we'll be
okay.
And I'm like,
why?
He goes,
just trust me.
We're okay.
And I swear to God,
I thought he might've had a gun,
but what do you buddy buddy buddy saying
like,
well that's going to be okay about.
Okay.
So he bought some weed from someone
bounces there and,
and,
and I didn't look because,
you know,
it's,
it's felony there.
So I just get it and we walk off and
while we will walk off,
we realized that I pick it out.
I said,
oh,
that is not enough.
So I go back and I say,
guys,
that's not enough.
You need to get me more.
And he goes,
no,
that's not going happen.
And he has this attitude.
I said,
okay,
well let me do it different.
I'm going to be back in 10 minutes and
we're going to be back in 10 minutes.
And then,
uh,
it better be here.
So we walk around,
we thought,
you know,
maybe we should look it up,
at least as we relax and we're in this
weird,
what is it,
a mailbox just like,
it's,
it's a complex.
And suddenly I'm reading and starts
jumping up and she start getting angry
and he hits a mailbox.
Ryan stocks and I'll try to keep this
book.
He's guys down and I go,
no,
you guys relax.
Relax.
I just to shut up my friend.
I say to write and right,
go talk to me.
Like this was saying,
come on man.
Are you really doing this right now?
Let we get this whole fight goes on.
I said,
no,
we got to stay relaxed.
You smoke a little weed,
we're going to go back.
Finally everybody calmed down.
We go back and these guys probably call
somebody,
but oh no,
no.
First of all,
these big guys.
And I walk over and say,
Oh,
so um,
we need to right now and they say all we
need to wait to,
because they're bringing it right now.
So right away already we're looking back
at sure enough,
there's two big guys coming.
Also same clothes as they have and you
can see them very sturdy walking up to
us and as soon as they see us,
they make a one 80 and it talked back
into fold.
Goes from the guy and I go,
those are the guys calling you right now
telling you you got to give it up.
And he goes,
he opens the phone and the guy and he
says,
okay,
and he puts it down and he gave us a
whole mountain founders.
It was right over a movie man.
It was hilarious.
But the whole altercation when
everything,
everybody started jumping.
That's what Quintin left.
Yes.
We have a great times.
Great Times.
Yeah.
Crazy Times.
Just a good time.
Yep.
How,
how much of a presence was the whole
Yakuza thing while you guys were there?
Like how?
How aware of you guys have it where you
guys know?
I know I was nobody.
Nobody would notice this launch and
drugs.
They don't do anything like that,
but real estate.
You saw people sitting down there.
Okay.
You said they were missing fingers.
Crazy.
That was where Masato boxer was
traveling into your organs.
They're all a strip club and this guy
sits there and I'm with long hair and he
comes over to me and says,
hey,
how you doing?
Like a little feminine and really weird.
You've got to be the biggest fan.
Are you be financial?
Oh,
now we got this crazy guy here,
right?
That I had no clue what to think.
And um,
he said,
oh,
you're a great fighter.
You want to know what I do?
And he takes his shirt off and it's all
padded up and people start literally
leaving the place there.
And I realized he's yogurts are right.
So we started talking.
I was talking about a n n,
a n a to that.
I wanted them this color.
I said,
but in America it's hard to find at that
time people only wanted to use black
ink.
And he says,
no,
that's not hard at all.
Why don't you come tomorrow morning and,
uh,
I can do this for you.
So the next day he and I,
we go to this dungeon,
like five stories under the ground.
It was the weirdest place.
We opened the door,
there is a cage would have back that
Masato which indicates two dobermans and
fly up against the thing.
It's like this human skulls everywhere.
This pictures of books killing people.
This guy taught me and he starts
screaming and older people are getting
to to it.
At that moment.
They all get up and they run out the
displays.
They locked the door and I look at
myself,
I'm like,
Ooh,
you know,
because this is a really weird
situation.
But no,
he wasn't.
He did a great work,
you know,
but it was.
He started looking.
We made it big picture.
Take a video of you.
I'm going to,
because I have a skull with a bullet
hole in there.
Record an audio will as well because
there was a cage where Masato used to
kickbox deadline,
so he would train in a cage in a
basement.
Well,
five stories below.
We kept going down.
It was the craziest thing.
If you think about they have,
you know,
you go like that with the Dobermans in
their regular trading joe.
But that's,
that's what the guy said that it was
Masato me may have even maybe had an
interest in Masato fought cool.
Vince Phillips,
who?
American boxing champion,
the boxer,
right?
And he went over and fought Masato,
Masato lift those legs.
Chagas animal at that time.
I mean even against the Dutch guy.
So you can find Masato versus weekends.
Phillips is really interesting to see
you lift those legs up like a Christmas
tree box.
Top flight.
American boxer fight against a kickboxer
prime max.
Two thousand three.
Yeah.
But you know,
in your.
Just accommodating my earl phillips in
his defense,
he was beyond his privacy.
His body had started to fade.
Well,
but he,
that he was kicking kicked across the
legs.
But who was it that took one kick and
got out of the ring?
Ray Mercer reimbursing,
knocked down,
but mercer was a with the Kimbo when the
MMA thing.
But it was the fighter winter,
Japan,
the American boxer and took one kick and
stopped.
Got Out of the rain.
Came on,
right?
Yeah.
It was more not more sense.
Nah,
I forgot.
No,
I,
uh,
yeah.
Similar.
Yeah.
It was a blonde guy.
But look at Masada was awesome sense.
Doesn't really helpful to the kids and
massage.
I was going across to cross the arms and
then across the back leg to rob came and
style.
He did a lot of that and he just moved a
lot and just kick those legs like every
time we there.
You see Phillips is already starting to
wear down and Masato was a good boxer to
men.
It's like you couldn't deny his hands.
I mean,
he might not have been the same box with
Vince.
Phillips was in prime.
We're all those leg kicks.
It makes such a difference.
Do you remember?
Go Me and Paul over at shockwave.
Uh,
I thought that was some of the best mma
boxing bus we'd seen at that time would
really.
And he goes down.
He just couldn't get up.
Did you remember that film?
He knocked him down.
What about her hair?
We're taught off as well,
Sergei.
We're taught early in pride show.
Good box.
Everyone has that debate and argument
about,
oh,
boxing.
How would they do it?
We know it's two different sports,
but when it comes to that aspect of MMA,
the boxing will start.
Gameplan indicate one surgeon,
he had quite a few [inaudible] and then
recently got back into mma,
right.
Didn't,
he didn't do,
but he got clipped.
Complete animal guy.
He used to train the fader.
I remember all the way back.
That was one big group because that
remembered a split at the time and
watching what happened to him.
You know,
he was a great guy to illustrate.
Funny,
Nice Guy.
One of the scariest stoppages I oversaw
was um,
uh,
was against semi shelt.
Do you remember when he mounted semi
shelter and got on top of them and like
a mounted triangle and start smashing
Aratana punching them.
Whoa.
Whoa,
whoa.
Hey everybody.
He's just punching them in one eye over
and over and over.
I remember that.
That was sent me.
Shit,
man.
Such a physical.
He just didn't have the ground round
exactly with Keratin on right then.
And Keratan off.
Just took him onto.
I mean that was back when she sent me,
was beating everybody in key with that
long Friday.
Crazy at the time.
The first time I sold for change it,
I was commentating this fight in the
Ukraine and uh,
it was a while ago.
That was a really.
Did the whole trip was a wild trip.
Oscar Charlie Anzalone,
you know the folks from Vegas,
um,
but he,
he put in an eight men tournament.
He was the lightest guys,
like under 90 pound tournament and he
destroyed all these guys.
I think the lightest guy,
he fought to a supple violence.
That was the lie.
This guy at two to 3:30.
It was insane.
I mean,
do I need just knocked everybody out and
I go like,
this Chechen guy gets a pretty good.
I remember he fought on this big giant
matt once they did something that was
almost like they made it up a basketball
court and he fought on it.
It's an interesting thing,
but I've been bringing this up a lot
lately.
I really think mma we'd be better off of
the largest surface and no cage,
just like a basketball court,
just like that site.
Welford sightlines definitely.
I agree with you and teach us.
What about what came up against the kid?
That's cool.
Metamorris type fighting surface for
MMA.
I don't weld.
The problem metamorphosis is elevated,
right?
Like you don't want to do.
It's fallen.
No,
no,
exactly.
But that kind of like that'll do space.
I think a big open space on the ground,
just mad at ground level.
You almost to let a cage though to had
they had the tip for cameras is not
gonna work.
It's gonna be very hard for the audience
to see as well because it's all one
level,
but that's in a lot of people.
Accord is all one level.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
A lot of people say though when they go
to an event that they are watching the
screen because of that,
but I think you could do it on a
basketball court,
but just think that it.
It dates still see here at a basketball
boards,
the people on the floor,
they can at least see the cage,
the bottom of the cage,
but if somebody sits in front of him,
they can't see anything.
Well,
if you have tiered seating,
if you have like stadium style seating
and then there's be a front row and then
there's gotta be some sort of dividing
line because you don't want to get run
over if you're in the front row.
Some fucking gorilla.
It's like wrestling a college wrestling.
Yeah.
If a referral comes piling through and
slams on your girlfriend and breaks both
her legs or Travis Browne,
it was in the front row.
Yes,
it could be a problem,
but it could be an issue.
The front row,
it could be an issue,
but as long as they keep people from bug
piling into the crowd because if you
could have that,
you would be able to watch something
happened with no cages.
There's one thing that I see over and
over again,
like it's a very grueling aspect to mma
when guys are tied up against the cage
and they're clenching and it throw a
nice the body and they're throwing
elbows and titan is a grueling sort of,
but it's also grueling in an artificial
way like it's artificial that they're
pressed up against something and that
that cage becomes a factor in the fight.
What it doesn't have to be a factor.
I think the more factors you can remove
extraneous factors outside of your
opponent,
the better to fall is an extraneous
factor and you could use it to your
advantage.
Be pressed people up,
he'd take them down with it.
There's a lot of things you could do to
get back up from it,
but I really feel like it's an automatic
brake or is that taking too much that
away for the fight.
If you go against the fence,
I stopped.
I'm still going to have electricity on
the fence that that would be something I
championships,
but it will hold people who are total
savages.
They would hold someone against the
fence,
see who could take the pain,
the most bold jolted to the difference
going from a former ring to a cage is
already huge because there's no corner,
so I can only imagine that that means
she'd know the wool walking no more.
Everything that Bernard Hopkins knockout
last week,
not last week,
last month or so,
went through that ring like that and
fell down on his head.
I was like,
how do they not protect against this?
We have to remember there was a real
pride frank to already there with their
numbers on their back.
Remember this kid that was.
But that was always one of the problems
about the pride ring,
right?
You were forced to break lion fight too.
I was watching one,
a car Hollenbeck's fights and he,
he fell out of the ring and smacked his
knees on the edge of the,
uh,
apron as he was falling out.
I remember Marvin Eastman falling out of
a ring of Vancouver almost seriously
hurting himself as well before he got
the goats for Jonah.
Why don't they have like a netting in
between the ropes to keep prevent people
from falling through?
It still serves the same purpose.
You would think so,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
more vertical rope to swell in between.
Do you remember the old valley to doe
fight between Palae and Chuck Liddell?
Yeah.
They had a net under the first rope.
The bottom row was shoving them in there
and they were bare knuckle fighting
chocolates,
punched him in the face,
bare knuckle,
and he couldn't escape.
He would just tucked in there like a
fish fuck beat out of them.
Jesus Christ.
Gary Goodrich with the Pedro.
When he went to squeeze the pillow does.
Yeah.
He went right into his pants and grabbed
a hold of his junk and crushed his balls
in his hand and he had some grit.
Man,
I can tell you,
I listened to a hotel one time and
getting a massage and while I'm getting
the massage to the girl that put a towel
over your face,
right?
So I don't know who's massaging me.
And suddenly the massage gets stronger
and stronger and stronger as she starts
crushing my shins.
You know,
like really hot,
I throw the towel and go,
hey,
and it's a big data,
good risk taking over to massage my
legs.
So I know he has a grip.
Yeah.
What a crazy thing that was a rule.
You,
you were allowed to grab the balls and
so what about the rules will never see
knees to the head.
Right?
Under the unified rules,
they just implemented some more rules
than you.
You want it to get rid of the midnight
to 12 to six,
but they changed that,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
We should explain to people what it
means in mixed martial arts.
You not allowed to drop an elbow down
from like vertical.
You can drop it from 12 to 6:00
and the only reason why that was
invented back in the day when the
commissions were approving mma,
big John Mccarthy had to meet with them
and they wouldn't let anybody do that
because they had seen people break
bricks on espn by dropping elbows like
that.
And like if someone could pick a brick,
they could kill a person can do it like
this.
Right.
It's so stupid.
I mean,
it's probably like one of the,
I wouldn't say it's the week,
it might be my weakest elbow,
but I.
it's one of the weaker elbows.
Yeah.
I don't think it's nearly as strong as
that kind of elbow pleasure.
If you hit a skull and I can tell it's
totally still splinted for me when I
fall.
Adrenaline and.
Okay.
That was from three to whatever you want
to,
you know,
that door,
horizontal elbows,
but still you don't want to hit.
It's.
Yeah.
You get field as little pieces.
You know,
it's,
it's from this call from Kevin.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
it's just a dumb rule,
you know,
and that's the one blemish and Jon Jones
record when he fought.
Dropping those elbows.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Totally legal.
Yeah.
I don't know why they haven't put that
back in a while.
I thought that's what they were going to
do.
Maybe they hit an nice socket,
may bend to.
I could be really damaged,
but then again you can do that standing
like someone could tomahawk you standing
and it could go right into your eye
socket about soccer kicks and stomps Mr.
Rogen.
Well,
see,
that's one of the things that we could
have if we had a basketball court,
you know,
you would have soccer kicks on the
ground like for sure.
I think so,
yeah.
I think violent.
I've never punched somebody on the
ground.
You should be able to kick a member of
when he was.
First of all,
the stomping is great,
but I couldn't believe it tomorrow.
Right.
Condo condo veteran,
who's actually cut the Czech Republic
tomorrow.
Why he?
Well,
he saw a box team.
Mauricio Shogun Hua loves soccer.
He did.
He,
he pedaled kick this big ring Sakharova.
His face looked like the elephant man to
that.
There were some violent tendencies.
Environment I think is probably once
when Sakharova fought.
Melvin manhoef.
That was horrendous.
Melvin was coming up in his prime and
Sakharova was on the way down in.
Melvin was arguably one of the scariest
strikers of all time.
Just unbelievably violent.
Just took violence to a totally
different level,
knocked out Mark Hunt.
You know what?
I think he had a double mark,
had a double knock out there and I,
you got to pull it up to see if I'm
right.
I believe if my shirts,
we was locked out twice,
you know,
he was knocked out and when he fell down
he hits the cup also for maneuver and we
had all of the old steel cups and he
hits a talk.
He falls down,
he sees boom under coping.
I think maybe that sealed the deal,
right?
They're just saying,
we'll find that.
Find that story.
Mark hunted.
Well now we will probably.
Or what's he doing with the lot.
But again,
another guy,
he's a,
he's got the UFC because the UFC day
he's saying that they knew here here's a
fight.
Oh,
hold on.
Go right here.
I hope my charges paid him full under.
Yeah.
I need bumps and forward with the Times
on the way down to go and mark the cost.
Yeah,
right into the steel account man.
And it's like he was sprawling almost.
You push his hips forward.
Wow.
Yeah.
He was,
he still is an animal.
The guy that ever lived
by the sword wore one of those steel
cups.
Will is a mere renova already.
He used to wear one of those steel cups
and he'd get on top of mount.
Yet with that fucking Steel Cup,
he was quite the goddamn weapon.
Press it into things that he was the
star of your stag stag.
Still people that are under steady in
half.
God,
if I shouldn't have gotten somebody,
have God right,
and if I sit in it,
I grew up in bite ahead.
I can literally bounce his own knee into
his face.
That's an illegal move.
MMA,
and it's a real easy thing to do.
Imagine that.
The Nice right over here,
just thrust my hips forward.
His own knee will bash in his face and
ask big.
Joe Mccarthy says,
yeah,
that's illegal move.
So I go,
man,
I haven't seen anybody do that.
But that little lid knocking himself
out,
but different way.
See,
you're pushing his head into his knee.
No,
I grab his head.
By the time he can not push me backwards
and then I drive my hips forward and his
own knee because his leg is here over
here,
I can fit into his own face and he's
going to stop my hip power,
which is going to be very hard to do for
him,
for him in that same position.
Hm.
Have you drilled that?
I in my class.
I teach it.
Yeah.
Huh?
Guys pull that off.
Oh,
it's a real easy thing.
It's very hard for you to stop me.
That's interesting.
We can jump into my,
you,
I can show it to you.
Isn't that funny?
When people learn things and you go,
oh,
well there's that now,
right.
You know,
for a long time guys would go uh,
and they would go and throw under hooks
on like from the half guard and then
they would try to like sneak up to your
body and then work their way in.
But then people started Darson people.
So then that under hook became like a
real liability for those long arm Doris
guys.
And that's just sort of had a,
it had a change,
you know,
it had a,
people have evolved.
We've installed an early days with the
kickboxing Tyberg book show,
Ramon Dekkers,
you know,
in the clinch,
pushing somebody away,
boom,
hiking and it went down and then you see
everybody starts doing it,
then everybody knows you that doesn't
work anymore.
And then he did.
He pushed away with the low kick and I
go,
wow,
when I teach this a lot in my class too,
because if I push you,
you're off your balance shifts backwards
show you don't flex your leg.
That low kick doesn't need to be hard.
Trust me,
because the muscle is relaxed.
It goes straight through.
So a little while you kick as a very
good thing to do.
You look at the expeditious evolution of
it.
When we go back and remember doing
voiceover for some pancreas,
have fights for fight network in Toronto
and,
and you know back where you go and you
watch a sport under what was mma rules
and well there's that,
there's that,
but it just didn't exist to them at the
time in there.
The,
the,
the mindset or the,
the drilling as you say,
and it's,
it's,
it's interesting when you look at now
people who,
that's all they've trained in guys like
a courtyard,
pat for instance,
and all these kids,
Tj dillashaw where it's,
it's,
I love this growth.
There's only a certain amount of moves
that you can do right there.
Like armbars.
Everybody's always just chokes.
It's Dah weight towards
those.
If you find a different way going
through that certain Armbar,
then you surprise somebody and that you
see that happening a lot.
Suddenly it as a triangle choke,
the new triangle,
choke setup.
Then everybody starts doing it and it's
gone again,
but it's just about that.
The move is there,
but what the setup is every certain
kicks,
right?
Well,
karate and taekwondo.
Same thing that you thought,
oh,
that would never work,
and all of a sudden everyone's know for
a while.
The front kick to the face and frank
with you seen that with wonderboy.
Wonderboy is perfect example of what I
thought was going to be the next stage
of evolution as the sport karate guys.
The guys,
you know,
like Michael Venom page,
Raymond Daniels,
Daniels,
and what these guys are doing is they're
showing that if you have all those other
skills will then those traditional
martial arts techniques become very
novel and people don't know what to do
with them.
Like with wonderboy and he started
stabbing people with that front leg side
kick and then throws that frontline
round kick.
People don't know what to do with.
Cool.
And he's also got that crazy style of
leak leaning back and forth like a snake
popping back in.
It's gonna be very interesting to
rematch though because I think.
I think even though it was a draw,
I guess according to the score card it
would be a draw.
When you look at who did more damage,
it's clearly woodley woodley did way
more damage in two rounds he had.
He had wonderboy and some serious shit.
Yup.
And also for whatever inexplicable
reason,
and he doesn't even know why I asked him
about it after the fight.
He didn't take them down after the first
round.
Am I cute?
You know,
he was like,
if you asked me right now,
I have no idea why I did and he's like,
I got 20 years of wrestling,
you would think I would use it,
and he had so much success in the first
round,
taking them down.
But then again,
he almost knocked him out in the fourth
round to remember he stunned them in the
fourth round,
just shoulders,
eyes,
book.
Yeah.
It was,
um,
it was a pretty,
it was an interesting fight because
would wonder.
Boy Did regain some points and regained
some ground,
but he never really had woodley in any
real trouble.
And I think that is always the ultimate
point of fighting is like who puts the
other person in grave danger?
And clearly woodley put wonderboy in
grave danger.
He had him stand.
Deanna fucked up.
He was beating him up.
He caught them.
He had them in a guillotine,
looked like his head was gonna pop off.
He had him in far more dangerous.
The cutesy was something else.
Scrase escaped.
I'm out.
I just wonder how.
I wonder how he holds his hands.
You know,
because there's some guys that are,
it's a diy,
there's different ways to hold your
hands where you can really like
accentuate the bone into the neck and
really there's little minute details and
gay teens that you never know.
Right.
That's the Alpha male members of wicked
ones.
Yep.
And of course Marcello Garcia.
So he's probably got one of the best
teams I've ever seen in history.
Grappling competition.
Yup.
You know,
and then cody mackenzie had that fucking
crazy squished down the side and that's
what John Jones used to go to prayer.
Hey,
old marine during pride days member,
he had a slick year team.
Vito Belfort,
right?
He's in my class like a while ago,
there was in my old gym and we've been
working out tonight teaching my class.
I say,
Hey,
would you like to teach that guillotine
to the,
to the guys?
Yeah,
sure.
He said,
yeah,
put me in as far as so I could feel how
it is.
But he went freaking 80 percent and I
go,
Whoa,
whoa.
I mean that was a scam.
Why?
Because she's got these long arms,
you know,
and they,
they go around and it's like the prayer
becomes a bloodshot instead of just
crushing the windpipe.
Yeah.
He's so jacked.
He's,
he's such a fucking giant dude too with
those long arms,
you know,
you show to see him doing like lifting
cars and all that stuff that he didn't
hold it,
that walking with like 150 kilos,
you know,
75 kilos in each thing and then running
with it,
you know,
like a suitcase.
Again,
another guy who represents redemption in
the sport and you,
you'll here now what's going on with
Rhonda and everything,
but even mark Carney,
mma,
I'm,
you know,
I spent a few years now doing boxing.
We're one last ruins your career.
It seems for whatever stupid reason,
but in mma there are so many redundant.
Even overeem has been up,
down,
up.
There's still a bad narrative and
boxing,
unfortunately someone who loses a fight
doesn't come back.
It was going to help that I think for a
bit.
It did.
I mean,
Bernard Hopkins had an old fame career
after losing his first fight.
So I don't understand that.
Then Gable,
Dan Gable,
he uh,
we were interviewing him and he saw this
record and like,
but with randy couture record another
record and he goes,
like,
he's a world champion,
but we're talking to a guy who lost once
in his life,
you know,
so he goes,
oh,
I didn't know that.
He was totally shocked by it.
Many ways to win,
many ways to lose,
right Wayne,
different world people are throwing
their punches and kicks and catching you
with knees and take them down.
Cro Cop was,
the guy told us in Japan that if you
don't lose an mma,
you really haven't fucked.
Had been.
He was trying to make the point of,
you know,
it's,
it's so tough guys that are gonna
happen,
man.
It's also evolving.
It's radical pace.
I mean,
you're seeing all these new approaches
constantly changing.
So many great minds involved.
Yeah,
that's what I liked.
I mean,
ferris a hobby and I made want the list
can go on.
But that's what,
that's what I become now a bit more of a
nerd because you call so many fights in
you.
You try to have a life as well,
but I'm really now getting back into,
okay,
let's catch up and see what these
different minds of sang well and you
yourself sir,
even,
you know,
listening to this,
it's just always so cool to,
to hear different perspectives and.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's super important for all of us.
I think that's why Bj's going to do
good.
It really,
I truly believe drinking because he
changed camp.
I think talent,
like Bj in his training in Hawaii,
you know,
he kinda dictates whatever he wants to
do.
He's so talented.
He schools people around and that's why
when you put people like that on the
pressure,
they get tired because they never
experienced that enduring because he's
so way ahead above everybody else.
So if they want to do extra three rounds
with him,
he prayed and he doesn't want to do it.
He's going to gonna I'm not going to do
I.
it's a bad example that
drake at Greg Winkeljohn,
you know,
and there he's got all these guys
gunning for him.
It's Alegent.
I mean I can only imagine the sparring
sessions they have going on.
I think it's going to do really well for
him now.
His opponent?
Yeah.
Rodriguez is really good know,
so.
Okay.
But I had a conflict the whole honestly
the.
He's a hall of Famer.
Done everything we saw against Frankie
Edgar.
What is it?
We talked about our podcast.
The last one was Matt Hughes.
Twenty 10.
Do you.
Why do you think he's still fighting?
Well,
he probably feels like he didn't do it
right.
He probably feels like the fights he
took with Frankie where you had that
really bizarre standup stance here was
the weirdest thing I've ever seen.
He decided that he was going to fight
that way because it was more efficient
and it didn't use as much energy as
widening his stance and he,
I think a lot of his career he was
concerned with losing his energy in the
ring.
Yup.
A lot of his crew.
He's worried about gassing.
Yep.
So then he went with [inaudible].
Right.
So he does these two camps with Marvin
intervention at least two camps.
Correct.
He did.
Sean Sherk and I.
Thank you.
Did Diego Sanchez?
I know he did.
Diego Sanchez,
because I know also that Steve Maxwell
was training Diego Sanchez got Sanchez
in incredible shape,
but that was Bj in his prime and when Bj
wasn't tired when he was in shape and he
was joking around about it,
like when I have a six pack here before,
what was it?
He wasn't just a different animal back
then,
but it was only sustainable for like a
few fights.
I think Bj,
it's for whatever reason,
it was hard for him to get totally
motivated to get into that kind of shape
again.
And when he described it,
it sounded hilarious.
Like he couldn't hold his daughter,
literally,
literally so tired after working out
that he couldn't even hold his kid.
And they have a very specific training
philosophy to the marina bitches.
And uh,
in a lot of ways,
um,
uh,
some of the guys that like Nickerson who
trains under his philosophy and speed of
sport in California,
they want strength and conditioning to
be number one priority number one.
You already know how to fight.
I love that.
Yeah.
And the idea is like,
you already know how to find it.
Okay.
So since you already know how to fight,
you should just work on having the most
incredible aerobic threshold,
which is back to frank and a plan to
Ortiz.
Well,
yeah,
but even Franco with the.
Why am I going to Kip Maury Smith with a
new partner show you in the beginning,
that's what frank was all about was the.
Couldn't be cardio.
The cardio was so important on the bus
back when Tito lost you,
frank.
I was in the same bus going back to the
airport that Tito was jump next to me
and he starts asking me a question about
seven because I always said is the most
important thing.
You can never have enough stamina.
That's the most important choice that
asking drills and doing all these
things.
And then he became that crazy cycle,
cardio cardio,
you know,
and he started beating everybody.
So he was transferred that to Kendall
Grove and one of the guys on the train
into the ultimate fighter Kendall came
out of that show and that's what he told
me.
He was like,
it's all cardio,
man.
Everything is about cardio when.
But again,
cardio also.
What about the nerves then and how much
panicking and your emotions drained?
Like what I'm saying plays factor in it,
but the actual real cold hard cardio
plays a factor too.
Then it also plays a factor in your
nerves because if you know that you have
a small gas tank and you started your
lit up.
Yup.
And especially when you walk to the
ring,
did I train hard enough?
You know,
if you know that you can really go,
you know,
after work I done,
we'll do seven,
six minutes round.
So that type at full blast,
that's like 42 minutes and.
But that was after a workout but I knew
that nobody did that so I was not going
to run out of gas because we had half
our fights in Japan but it's the only
way to do it.
Constantly go hard.
And I had guys coming who couldn't do
the warmup in my class is a 20 minute
warmup,
is the boss where to work with the
sprawls and at a minutes I fill them up
with the idea pushups or with the
kettlebell swings.
So it's 20 minutes straight.
People come in who had a fight like in
two weeks in Japan and it couldn't do
it.
They had to man.
I said,
don't fight.
He said,
what do you mean?
I said,
this is the warm up.
It didn't even start now and let's say
they lost because of cardio over there,
but how.
But how do you do it?
As I said,
it's just baby steps it.
You just get yourself to the point where
you can get through that entire warmup,
full clip and then just.
Yeah,
just keep doing it.
Who can do things?
So best conditioned athlete right now in
MMA or what?
Like what are names that come to mind?
Is Alaska's right away I would think.
Right.
Cane and he's a freak.
He's afraid.
I mean there's a lot of really good guys
down 90 miles.
Right?
He's tired,
but he's also so efficient.
You could also say the same thing about
cody and dominic.
Yeah,
I was going to say that was more civil
war for 25 minutes.
No,
you're right.
There's a lot more.
It's becoming a bigger deal.
In the early days it was only the WC
guys because I've got a lighter guys,
but now everybody,
while they hit me the most,
if a guy comes in with no cardio for
three rounds,
I go,
you're serious.
It's like bringing a half a can of
paint.
If you're a painter too,
you do the door half.
Yeah.
That's the only thing I have.
It's the same thing.
But your ds,
the Ds Boys,
Nick and native.
Uh,
always.
I mean,
when you think of wow,
the triathlons,
know that he swam from Alcatraz five
times now five times now the podcast,
like,
what the fuck?
He's coming.
Is he coming back soon?
Let's go get some,
a world title fight.
There are a bunch of miles.
Yeah.
Look,
I,
I thought like,
you know,
crazy would be of connor fought
nickname.
Now you say so they're already saying
that connor,
that he shouldn't have fought nate
because nate was too big for him,
but he made his a one.
That's a fight that's going to happen
again.
You have to.
Connor stays the 155 pound champ.
Do you remember going to happen again?
Oh,
I wonder if it's on a grid.
You Remember Diaz in daily?
Sitting there and just calling him like
twice.
He was knocked down twice back and
stopped him with three seconds left
recoveries.
Always fantastic.
That seminar in Goma and then the
fricken thc.
Why did they test for that?
While we don't want to get into that
now,
I'm sure is an athletic conditioning.
Tests tests forever.
All my friends,
they're tell you.
Okay.
They're saying now that they're gonna
they're thinking about calming down on
that and then not.
Not even caring if people test positive.
Well,
I hope so.
Which would be a good thing because the
way the level show in your skin and the
way it stays in your fat,
like if you got high the night before a
fight,
you're not going to feel it during the
fight.
You just not.
But if it's an of will show up maybe.
Yeah,
but you'd have to really fucked up and
over and you'll probably get new ideas
on his podcast.
I have not ever seen anybody.
One of those gummy bears was like
$1,200.
The only guy I think he ate ate,
that's so insane.
Like that writer from the New York
newspaper went to Denver and did a piece
and she ate a whole shock by guests who
was like eight different doses or how
many different doses and talk wrote
about her good oil.
Yeah,
you shouldn't be paranoid.
You're a little flesh bag on the planet.
My daughter went to a planet totally
through infinity.
You should be nervous as fuck.
Ever.
We'd go rock could fly on the sky and
kill you.
I thought I took it.
I made a quiche.
Some cookies.
This is eight,
nine years back.
And uh,
I,
I crank one because they're heavy
cookies and while I'm eating a little
crumble fulls of the ground and I,
I see the dog right away running over
it.
I want to stop it and I go,
you know,
but the little tiny bit,
right.
So I'm eating it and I have to pick up
something from a friend of mine who was
like 20 minutes away here somewhere in
the valley.
Uh,
I go pick it up,
I'm back in the car and as soon as I'm
in the car started driving and it hits
me.
I'm going to hit and within two minutes
I got a phone call from my wife.
What did you do?
I remember talk outside,
staring outside for like two and a half
hours.
No,
which is looking at site.
It was the funniest thing.
I came home.
He was just like poor,
poor Louis has been high a few times.
Luna doesn't like men,
but she made a connection,
but no,
that's a rather intimate one.
She doesn't like men for some reason.
She,
oh,
she will go after you.
Wow.
Kits and women are cool,
but a guy,
oh,
the mailman literally does the dog that
will go a full mode attack.
It is a little dog is 15 pounds.
So it's the dog,
a poodle.
I love that.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Her.
How's your arm?
It looks like you're getting a lot of
muscle back and your arm.
You know,
at the top.
I'm getting it back,
but you see below there still something
to be done.
I'm here with an a in the valley.
There's a doctor now and he does these
crazy injections also.
Uh,
and it's elite.
It's caught to nervous scorch somewhere.
So.
And I feel that something is caught
costs.
Yeah.
So
to impinged.
Yeah.
So what they say is if you take a fire,
a water hose,
if you squeeze it,
water comes out.
That's the same with an nerf action
comes out and that apparently they made
this special,
a picture that they only could do in,
uh,
Santa Monica and they saw that it was
blocked there and he can apparently he
can inject me there and they will take
the pressure off and he,
he believes that that's very possible
that we'll come back then.
So yeah,
it's crazy because she stepping,
my fingers is still very hot and I get
this.
But I could do that for four years.
Wow.
That even snapping my fingers.
So slowly but surely it works.
I just work out the arm and the shoulder
shoulder comes back also a little bit.
That's the thing that they say about
nerves,
right?
That any kind of nerve damage takes a
tremendous amount of time to heal
because nerves,
they grow vag very,
very slow,
very slow people.
They don't understand it.
I always say it's like digging the spark
plug out of a,
a cylinder that's your nerve.
Once the nerve is broke,
you take that out,
it's gone.
And then to atrophy comes,
you know,
because people go like,
how can you then be paralyzed?
I said,
what happens with people who bring it
up,
right?
Yeah.
I said no more nerves going to the legs.
She can't walk anymore.
And that's the same thing what I have
right now.
Only the nerve is still there.
It's just pressured.
I ran into some kid after a show the
other day and we were talking about neck
injuries,
uh,
and Jujitsu and he was asking me a
question and he's like,
my arm doesn't work under here.
My tricep starting to fade away.
And Mike,
dude,
go to a doctor yesterday.
You got to get an Mri as soon as you
start seeing atrophy and as soon as you
start feeling numbness,
you got to get on it right away.
Yep.
Any impingement to necklace because
there are some ways that they can sort
of relieve the pressure and spinal
decompression and a bunch of different
platelet rich plasma type of injections,
like Regena keen and stuff,
but you got to do something and you got
to do something quick and you can't keep
rolling.
All these guys,
they want to keep going to Jujitsu.
Even when their back's fucked up like
that.
And then like as you're rolling,
you feel like you feel like that twinge
and shooting,
doing real damage to yourself.
You've got to be super careful with any
kind of nerve injuries.
I waited too long.
That was the thing with me.
I realized I saw my arms slinking and
then I go,
oh,
I gotta go to the doctor.
But it was already.
I should've gone faster as soon as the
pride.
Why?
Why didn't you go sooner?
I don't know.
I thought it was going to fix itself.
I've been this indestructible guy from
my windows from rooms that are not your
thing,
you know?
I mean I feel I'm from a roof.
I fell on my face on the other step and
I put all my t stayed in.
It's the craziest thing.
You can tell by my front teeth.
I have something,
but I mean,
how did my feet did not come out.
I mean that was quite a fall.
You fell on your face from a roof.
You know what happened.
So you know those,
how you call those letters,
you know the,
the,
the feet pointed one.
I'm very smart.
Of course it's stands like this and I'm
standing it up and I'm pushing something
and of course when I push the ladder
stairs like this,
I pushed myself away and I'm following
all the way down,
see a slow motion coming because one of
the,
one of those stats things I go like,
oh,
I'm going to fall on it.
I realize I'm going to go slow motion.
So I stuck my arms out.
I think I'm good,
but it was longer than my arm for,
oh Geez.
I train on that thing and it wasn't even
dazed.
I go like,
oh,
a very gentle.
I went to my mouth,
I go,
please be in it.
You know,
and all my tooth fairy is insane.
Right.
That would have killed 80 percent of the
population.
You walk away with no loose teeth.
That's fucking hilarious,
man.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So in all the times when you guys were
working in pride,
how did you see like when they were
doing the.
We've given guys big bags of cash.
We guards there for.
Oh yeah,
we got those back because for us to come
to tell them about the first time.
But what you wore when you went to the
bank,
you know,
the first time I got paid,
the first night Bushido you had to come
and tell me,
hey,
this is,
this is what's going to go.
Because they're always just like you
when you go into the bank.
A bank,
right.
Perfectly packed.
You know Chris' notes.
I mean it looks like a monopoly money.
Y'All really crisp $100 American bills.
I was living in Canada.
He was afraid I had to actually cry.
I crumpled they up because when I
brought brand new bills,
I mean obviously they could tell it
wasn't counterfeit,
but they'd always look and go,
what is this?
That's literally every,
every show,
brand new $100.
Million was always in the back of your
head.
You go like,
I remember one time guns,
people to fight us.
They will talk over each other.
Okay,
let's let Bob.
So go ahead.
What?
Every fight.
If I'm like,
they say,
okay,
from 10:00
AM tomorrow morning you can come and
pick up your fight.
There was only one room and every single
fighter would ain't gonna.
Even guys like miracle Crocapo I know me
like 2 million bucks or something.
But they made a lot of money at the
time,
you know?
And they gave everybody cash.
So I assumed they gave him Cassius well
and I always thought men.
But then again,
if the equity has evolved and maybe
don't want to do that,
right?
Yeah,
you definitely have to bring 10 grand.
Didn't remember they were telling family
members.
Here's your stacks marker.
I mean everybody on our team at the
whole 10,000
feet,
10,000
because she can't bring more defense
out.
She took one bill off,
so it was less than 10.
Had the roles in Rappongi.
That is so crazy.
Yeah,
that was wild,
but it looked nice.
It looked cool.
When you came back,
you felt you felt good.
I felt like a criminal,
criminal.
The big rural Mexico actually got
$2,000,000
in cash from the heavyweight Grand Prix
and then put that in a suitcase and went
back to Croatia.
That's one of the most gangster fucking
things I've ever heard in my life.
I mean,
that's like that's a scene in a movie.
Be beat the fuck out of everybody.
A little title case you.
When that sperm tournament,
remember those sperm posters?
Fucking person was awesome.
One of the posters.
I feel bad I got rid of.
I had that post shirts or pluck.
Remember that upright or plug?
What does that mean?
Nobody knew and what lights that there
is no such thing as doing so.
There's no sort of doing things as
usual.
There's no such thing as doing things
such as usual.
He said,
I got to get the t shirt.
That is the dumbest thing.
Nobody's going to get a member of the
Grand Prix poster with a woman
breastfeeding the baby.
Looks like,
what the heck is going on?
You have a Waleed Ishmael t shirt from
like 1998.
And it says,
don't be coward,
don't run off the fight.
And it says on it at the time,
wasn't a guy said he had made and he
showed me and it was a direct
translation for them.
Fulfill for fight,
for fight,
for good luck with that buddy fight,
but brutal miscalculations and
translations because I lead with it.
He was hilarious.
I remember he uh,
uh,
he was telling a story and then I
realized what a,
what I did.
Because you did.
It's just kind of,
you know,
I thought it was funny after my rental
man flight,
my base face was bashed in,
right?
So I blew my nose,
of course,
once I wasn't addressing one because
then I could do it.
I couldn't do it before.
So needless to say,
my eyes blew up and I never close.
I could almost see anything anymore and
we all wanted to go out and um,
and it guy there and he goes,
what are you going to do?
I said,
well,
give me one second ahead of the doctor
with me.
I say,
give me the,
the syringe with the widest couch,
you know,
so I stabbed in my eye and I stopped
sucking the blood out yet.
But that's when I heard he told that
story and he goes,
and this guy still see me in the Dah,
Dah slugging it out.
He puts some shade.
So like the freaking terminator.
And he says,
come on,
let's go do my accent.
That's what I heard that I go to now.
Now you see when you go back in time,
you go,
yeah,
that was maybe a weird thing to.
Right.
So you stuck them in your eyelids.
Like where did.
Yeah.
And I tried to find you,
you pull just nothing coming out.
You'd have a little further and suddenly
you get blocked.
When you do a blood test,
you're still just start pulling,
you know.
And then I did and I could see again
Jesus Terminator.
That is so ridiculous.
That is how many people have done that.
That's a super rare move.
Stick a fucking needle under the bag
under your arm and suck blood out of it.
I'd say you're in a very rare company to
try to try to stitch yourself up with,
uh,
with normal needles.
I did that as well.
I put a video in a long time ago.
My wife at the beginning said,
don't tell her that you were with your
daughters yourself up.
My daughter's filming.
The other one is playing music of the
fence.
The dog is walking over my lack
stinking,
super,
super antiseptic.
Oh,
you see this,
this third.
Oh,
you're fired a fast.
What was that cut from it.
People won't believe it.
I at the time I drank nonalcoholic beer
and I walk outside and I grab a six pack
of blackstone,
Alcoholic Beer.
I walk back in the six pack,
breaks the bottles,
hit the ground,
and it shoots against my leg.
And I walk inside and they go,
man,
this hurts,
right?
There's this weird.
And then I walk a few steps and this is
crazy.
So I pulled my pants down and I saw that
cut.
The piece of glass was still in it,
so I had to pull it out and not go to an
actual doctor.
Okay.
Because my wife was in Holland at the
last time I did that.
I was A.
I overtrained in the sun for a promotion
for the body action system and I have to
go to the hospital because I was 93
degrees my body.
I crying,
I couldn't hold anything anymore.
Everything started cramping.
It was the weirdest thing.
So they had to.
This was like when you were filming that
commercial?
No,
I did a workout video workout.
I did the whole workout into at noon in
the son Jesus on the top and how much I
wanted to look good on the camera.
So I was hitting the thing as hard as I
could,
you know.
And then of course I took all potassium.
I tried every because I knew what this
was going to happen,
but still I started cramping crazy.
So I went to the hospital,
they put like two backs in me,
then they put another two bags and the
bags are empty and it's and um,
we'd been there for a long time and have
my kids with me because my wife is in
Holland so they're there with me and
it's 4:00
in the morning now and they still don't
come back and it's already like an hour
and a half.
And I've been asking them and I,
you know,
I get angry.
So I say,
you know what,
let's go guilt.
What you'd never should do is pull it
out yourself.
If you do that,
you need to put pressure on there.
And now I know why that is because I
sprayed the whole room full of blood.
So then my,
my daughters had hold your finger on,
the other one is I pulled it out to say
I know we got to run.
So we run out of the hospital and escape
the hospital,
escaped the hospital because I was
dehydrated.
So then my wife has gone again and this
thing happens and she already didn't
like it.
That something crazy at the first time.
So I go,
you know what,
I'm not going to go to the hospital.
I'm going to be there again.
It's become this big story.
I'm just going to stitch it myself.
So I asked the girls to find a needle
for first like they do,
but it broke and I go no.
And then we followed one more left and
they're really not sharp.
You gotta really push to get it in there
and uh,
but it worked.
It worked out perfect.
I cleaned everything.
I cleaned the rope with alcohol swipes,
all that stuff.
And I start stitching it and uh,
well not much I can do my,
my daughter,
I go like,
I say,
oh,
it's just like Rambo.
I said,
and she goes,
who is,
who is Rambo Daddy?
Did he do it too?
I said,
yeah,
you do.
But who is she?
Oh,
sorry,
he's an actor.
He's.
Oh,
it was a movie.
Yeah,
it was in the movie.
So he did not do it for real.
Maybe you should do it.
Stitch themselves up either if you get
like a first aid kit with needles and
needle.
Yeah,
because if you have one of those
needles,
you know the little round ones,
the hooks,
it's an easy thing.
You go really fast but you slip off
because it's,
you know,
everyday the hardest things to go in.
So what you need to do it when you have
the cut,
like for instance,
if the one side,
this one here's the cut and here right.
You have to put your finger underneath
so make your finger underneath and then
you have to stab the needle there
because otherwise every time what
happens is this,
it slips off.
It doesn't go in.
So you had to put my finger on an IV,
going out what's easier.
So once you're from the inside going
out,
that was easier to do.
But the going in part,
that was hard because it kept slipping
in.
It was not a really sharp new.
Well yeah,
that seems like a lot of work.
Yeah.
But it's better go to the hospital for
four hours.
A crazy glued.
Something crazy.
Gluco all my students.
Yeah.
I got to go into the doctor.
Come here.
Who really works the best as long as
your finger doesn't get stuck on the
wound as you're applying it.
Oh,
who said that?
Somebody did that for fun with a friends
with his mouth.
Oh,
that's good for lips.
Ripped apart.
Scar tissue over your lips.
You don't want to hit the dumbest thing
I've ever seen.
It was a guy in Holland.
They.
They challenged him to put a pool ball
into his mouth.
Oh fuck.
So once it was in,
he did get it out.
They had to break stitch out to get them
out.
Yet he almost couldn't breathe with.
Gets the freaking ball was in his mouth.
Fix it to the next level is Christ.
Fucking Christ had a break his teeth at
the break.
Steve Thought,
oh my God.
What a fucking retard.
Oh my God.
Can you do it?
Yeah.
What are you fucking three,
three year old.
Don't put that ball in your mouth.
Probably with alcohol or you can't do
it.
Oh No,
no.
That is a problem.
Yeah.
Wow.
God damn alcohol.
So what is going on with inside mma?
Yeah,
just fake.
Just stopped.
I just stopped before that.
How long did you guys do it for?
Nine years.
I did I think nine show.
Yeah.
If I made that quota
nine years and then they just decided.
I mean it was one of the most respected
independent MMA shows on TV.
I love it,
you know,
it was a really guy.
I would have loved to have a little bit
more heads up what you know.
Well,
Hey,
when,
when does a problem time slot sucked?
That was the thing at the end do to,
to go 9:30
Pacific time.
The,
the east coast.
She's shut
everything down.
It was the most dvr show they said.
Yeah,
well I'm sure.
But people like to watch things when
their current too.
They have it at like 6:00
PM on a weeknight,
what we've been saying,
or several nights nights where you want
to be,
you know,
to be on a Friday night.
Like everyone's going.
Yeah,
they go out and show them.
Man,
it was a fun show.
We had a good run,
you know,
and uh,
we're,
we're back together to get her audio
version of inside mma,
I guess,
although we talk a other combat sports
as well.
Mondays we drop the combat sports
carousel,
buzzy Bazuto,
that's what it is.
And then we do a routine and Ramallah,
which is more us just riffing on pop
culture events and try to add some
positivity to try to find some good news
stories to share in this deeply divided
world of ours.
So yeah,
we just uh,
we enjoy working with each other and
it's been a,
uh,
a blessing to be a reunited with them in
here.
You're a busy dude,
man.
Are you still doing boxing commentary as
well?
Debbie?
Tupac pen and Glorious and well,
maybe not so much shitty longer,
although glory will always remain a very
near and dear to me.
But uh,
so timing and did they were upset that I
didn't go to Germany because I had a
boxing event that night.
Showtime is a first priority so we'll
see.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
I'm,
I'm doing a championship double header
on Saturday at Barclays on showtime.
Where a unification fight,
which I think this year in boxing,
because not a great year last year for
the sweet science and uh,
we're going to try to hopefully see more
of the best fighting the best finally.
And I think again,
you know,
people can say what they want about him,
it may match making everything else.
But the one thing I've always liked
about mma,
eventually you will see those,
the best fight,
the best.
And in boxing the politics and the money
kept that from happening.
Well that was the thing that kept fade
or out of the UFC,
you know,
they wanted his own promotion.
Yeah.
They want to code promotion.
We see how it helped us strike.
I mean,
I think everyone knows this by now.
That was the deal that broke the
proverbial camel's back with
strikeforce.
And showtime,
uh,
was the fader after he lost the,
they,
you know,
wanted to resign fader at that amount of
money.
A showtime.
The boss at the time said,
you know,
we need a fader or we're not going to
renew the deal.
And Doug strike forces owners,
the sharks at the time with coker,
uh,
they wanted out.
So that kind of set the ball in motion I
think to because I thought and I think
it would have still been very healthy
for the sport.
I thought strikeforce and the UFC man,
that was some good shows in strikeforce
as we know.
Look what the,
the alum have done in the UFC.
Amazing Organization,
man.
Yeah.
Between strikeforce and in WEC.
I mean there's been a quite a few
champions that have come from both those
elements and smart move by the UFC to,
to do what they did to make sure they
got exactly what I was.
A very smart move.
But there is something to be said for
competition for sure.
You know.
And uh,
I'm,
I'm really.
First of all,
I'm glad there's other combat sports are
getting more and more popular.
Like Bella tour.
Take boxing liked glory to glory is a
very,
a very prevalent.
We know,
but you,
you've helped push that needle as well.
My man.
And it's,
I'm glad because I think for me,
bud calling all these combat sports that
we've called in this society in the 21st
century,
kickboxing at the highest level,
I,
I pick it over everything.
It's one of the most exciting sports in
the world for sure.
Without a doubt.
And one of the things about glory is
that you know,
you.
This is,
even though it's an organization that
may be a lot of people have not totally
become aware of.
Sure.
There's world class world,
championship level talent.
The talent is not like at a low level at
all.
When you got guys like Niki hold skin
and you know what I mean,
there's so much good.
But it's again comes.
Okay,
let me go.
Why?
Why do you think it?
Everyone says we need American stars.
Just like with you and you know
everything.
Is that.
Why do you think Laurie is not making a
bigger imprint right now in America?
It's a good question.
I wish I had the answer to because
there's a lot of combat pilots already.
I mean the doc would have how many shows
they go to UFC.
So if you look at all the other ones,
but I don't know,
I understand that or not.
I think that's also very valuable to me.
Nothing drives me more insane than
hearing mma fans.
Boo and incredible ground game or two
athletes.
So I'm just saying,
hey,
if there's that segment,
there is this thing called glory.
Kickboxing is on UFC fight pass to now.
It's just I,
I'm just a little surprised in a
disappointed that it hasn't gotten a
little more traction because these guys
deserve it.
Man.
It's weird.
I think boss nailed it though.
I think there's too much to watch
already.
Well look,
we do this for a living and I don't
know.
I'm,
you're,
you're watching everything.
I can't keep up anymore when I'm on the
road doing wwe and UFC and a single bed.
Yeah.
Like I'll,
I'll watch.
I have to tape everything just so fast
forward and,
and like you say to save time,
Joan,
it's,
you know,
I can't,
don't dedicate six hours because I only
got two or three and I still want to
follow in cover and yeah.
And then if you want to file Moitai,
good luck with all of luck with all that
as well.
Yeah,
I mean there's just too many.
Too much.
You're writing what size?
The hardest thing to watch in terms of
like get it live on television paper for
you.
I mean if some worldclass fights that
are going on right now and there's no.
There's a lot of times there's no way to
get more type premier league remembering
again was there all these.
Nikki goes great,
but boom,
still owe me money.
They do that.
Of course they did.
Somebody organizations only money.
It is what it is.
That was a good organization.
They put together a good event rather
than together a great event.
And.
But I think in the boycott was there
were a couple corporate.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think the world class more time
worldclass a kickboxing or greatly.
Greatly underappreciated.
I think fight pass.
I mean the ESPN deal.
I think this helped a little bit and of
course being on fight pass.
I hope it was also.
I mean,
when I was doing the shows and keeping
track of social media,
you know,
there is growth.
It's not,
I don't think stagnated by any stretch
of the imagination,
but again,
it's in Europe.
It is,
it is popular.
Very good ratings,
right?
Uh,
the Netherlands and by not an ultimate
fighter of show,
we've talked about that.
Boxing.
I asked anybody gives a fuck about
those,
those as well where we have a problem.
Yup.
You know,
I think,
I think people have seen too much
reality TV.
I think the novelty of it all wore off.
I think when forrest griffin and Stephan
Bonner went to war and season one and
that whole,
that whole cast with Kenny Florian,
Diego Sanchez and it just,
it,
it was,
it was something special.
But then that was also before like the
real housewives and a million different
photos.
That TV in general,
like a member who wants to be a
millionaire when the was on one night,
25,
30 million.
That'll kick two nights,
three nights.
It's like everything else we do in life
when it's good or when it's successful.
Let's keep going.
Let's keep going until they run it into
the ground.
Yeah,
and it's also,
there's style,
there's trends.
People just get excited about certain
trends.
Then they get bored of certain trends
and I think reality shows in general,
I think it's hard for people to get
excited about a new one.
So if you had a new one is just about a
bunch of kickbox almost got to be
something more than what it would be
something for either a fight or Netflix.
You know,
why you can watch it in one time.
I think Netflix is the way to go
nowadays because you decide when you
want to write,
not just netflix and Amazon.
You've got a special on Netflix as well
with everything,
right?
Like,
uh,
we're,
we're then that's why to me kickboxing,
grieving him at me.
You can go like on your phone right
away.
Here.
Okay.
I got three minutes.
Boom.
What a fight.
Great stuff.
Okay.
I'm done.
Like it's digestible in those tiny
morsel.
But how do you monetize it?
How do you build a,
uh,
an audience that's consistent?
Well,
I think it's going to be a slow build.
It's not going to be like the UFC,
which kind of exploded,
blow from the ultimate fighter and most
sports don't explode like that.
They take a long time and several
generations to build a mma.
It was so unusual in that it the
excitement level from watching a high
level of fight was irrefutable to the
point where when people would watch
fights on TV,
they'd be so crazy and so exciting that
it was almost like undeniable.
Yeah,
you had to watch him.
He's just too many people watching.
Can take your eyes off of it.
That's the difference between,
I think kickboxing,
it just.
The gloves are bigger.
They definitely ponds but doing that
cage boy time.
Yep,
Yep.
That's not a bad idea.
It's a good idea,
but then you know,
you see it in a cage like,
well,
why can't he take them down?
I can always do a flying arm bar.
Yeah.
That's fun.
We can do a lot of things.
Yeah,
I mean I think the sport is still
growing phases.
I think as far as the talent level,
you definitely seeing what's going on in
women's mma.
Women's MMA is changing pretty radically
and quickly.
Yeah.
We saw that.
I mean,
look at a water sitting in Paige vanzant
for variety of reasons.
Again,
that's an eight.
It's weird how our society,
we're fixated the,
you know,
the good looking people who can fight
are getting these huge numbers.
Where shouldn't it just be in this
sport?
Okay.
You're a fighter,
you're talented fighter and I know for
some,
but it just seems like America
especially is about the cosmetics,
right?
Well,
Sorta,
but I don't know if that's totally fair.
I think what we have is we have this
giant pool of hardcore fans,
right?
Yup.
Who want to watch a tyron woodley versus
wonderboy too.
They want,
you know,
people want to watch this really good
fights.
Exactly.
There's that and,
but in order to make the really big
money,
you got to go outside of those folks and
yeah,
get that casual fan and also generate
interest in 100 percent of the hardcore
fans because there's some hardcore fans
that quite honestly,
we'll look at a fire and go,
you know,
I don't really give a fuck about that
fight for whatever reason that fights
not my fight.
I don't want to watch it.
And so that's a big pay per view night
for the UFC.
There's a certain percentage of even the
hardcore fans at it say,
you know what,
I feel better saving my 60 bucks and
then I'll find out an hour later who
want anyway.
And unfortunately
time before Mcgregor came,
it's always the lighter weight classes.
Right?
Yeah.
And that's a shame.
Here's the.
Is the roster too big you think for the
UFC in that respect?
Like are you.
Because even as we say,
we covered this,
we hardcore like it's,
there's,
there's a lot of fighters on the coil
wire,
you know,
okay,
this guy,
the guy got to fill out the cards.
I'm just wondering,
for guy you covers a,
does it works for the company,
do you think there's the roster is it's
too big or you're happy with the way it
is
now in terms of Mike's fights?
Right,
so if I said that I would really have to
do research before I save the rosters to
big,
but if they don't fight for if in this
roster,
the question then becomes where do they
fight because they have to get fight
somewhere and would it be better for
some of these lighter?
Not Lighter,
but a lighter inexperienced guys like a
Mickey Golf for instance,
who just right away now he's fighting in
the UFC and beat sage northcutts on Holy
Shit.
Now the kid's a star,
right?
He beats up on my phone because the
smart so now,
but he's also only a couple of fights
into his career.
If you were his manager and you cared
about them a lot and you're saying,
look kid,
you're really good.
He got real potential,
but you need to get some seasoning and
you need to get some seasoning and
against commensurate talent.
You know you want.
You want to fight guys that offer a
threat but that you can beat and you
want to build your way up to a guy like
Damien Maia.
Right?
But if you fight Damien Maia today,
you're probably going to get fucking
smushed good and you might get smushed
in a way that might destroy your
confidence for fucking years,
but then there's.
I guess there's a feeder leagues,
right?
Access TV.
What has done a good job?
RFA,
all these other groups.
I'm wondering the UFC if they want to
even invest to invest in something like
that.
Limited TV show of it now looking for
a fight so they.
I don't think they will do that,
but I always thought that they should do
an amateur division or something to use
an image of the vision.
That's kind of cool because you're wind
micky gall I think has potential to be a
superstar,
but if you're already.
He already beat north.
Y'all already been six.
Northcott,
Northcott.
Who's going to fight next?
Maybe barring Barberino.
If he fights in,
keeps winning like he's.
He's not too far out of a top 20 ranked.
Then all of a sudden you're in the
wolves,
Dan.
I mean,
maybe he's cool with that.
Maybe.
Look,
Jon Jones did it.
Yup.
How many fucking people are John Jones?
Yep.
No,
you're right.
When you get that kind of talent,
that's how Jon Jones is a real special
talent.
That's really.
It's undeniable takedowns.
He hit on Dan Henderson pure grappling
match.
Oh yeah.
He can do anything.
That's what I like.
He could submit you.
He can knock you out.
It's just.
He really thinks about his fight in the
coordinated for a guy that size under
pressure.
He's a fucking gym under pressure.
He just rides the horse drawn.
All right.
Was that what was his arm is hyper
extended.
Vituro caught them in a beautiful arm
bar.
Perfect arm bar from the guard.
Had a fully locked out.
It looked like it looked like it was.
Oh,
it was over,
but didn't panic.
John just wouldn't,
wouldn't tap.
Let his elbow get fucked up and then
went on to submit Vittorio.
It's crazy.
Well,
you know,
once,
once you're a fighter and you slap on
something and you think you got to do,
you put all your effort in and then you
lose it.
It does a little bit to some fighters to
their mental states,
you know,
they get depressed and then when you
turn it up,
you know it has the moment you want to
start turning it up because then you
destroyed a fighter.
Then you can get actually to go for a
submission.
So I think that's what happened there.
That was a unique fight too and that Jon
Jones dropped Vittori with the front leg
side kick to the body.
I was like,
that is a great technique for him
because he's so long.
You know,
when you're seeing the way wonderboy
uses it and some other folks use it and,
and sage Northcutt as a really good one
as well.
But you think those will bleak.
I use.
I have a feeling somebody is going to
get hurt and they're going to take them
out because it looks so dangerous.
And especially the guy like Jones,
again,
because she got so much power on top of
it,
if by any chance the guy just walks
backwards in his leg is stretched and he
gets hit at that moment.
Silva women with silk because there was
a fight.
I thought it would involve silverware.
I thought the same thing like this is
gonna end in a serious knee injury.
He would do from lake side kicks to the
knees.
He would just hit you.
I mean,
why not the right above the knee?
Just hyperextends you're neil.
It's a weird thing because it's very
effectively.
So how come,
how come you're allowed to round kick
the outside of the knee?
Which everybody does.
You know,
why you allowed to do that?
But you're not allowed to hyperextend.
I mean,
if you're not there when it happens,
you don't get hit or you,
you know what I mean?
It's one of those things.
It's like,
it is a very effective technique.
Holly Holm uses it quite a bit,
you know?
Uh,
she used it on Rhonda quite a bit in
that fight.
The lower low kick,
I call it,
you know,
the little logo there under CAF.
And who,
who was it?
Who broke his,
uh,
people are again,
if I was a pretty recent like three
months ago or something,
somebody broke his feeble because he got
kicked in the calf and they stopped the
fight.
Now I'm thinking I'm the go to walk into
it.
Wasn't uc other organization,
Huh?
Yeah,
I mean it definitely happens.
What about knees to the head of a
grounded opponent?
Joe?
Are you a fan?
Well,
or blue thing could,
should be allowed.
This is what I think.
I mean,
I think that if someone is shooting for
a takedown,
here's,
here's a question.
So like say if a guy is in the process
of a double leg and someone's knee
touches the ground,
the guy shooting for that double leg,
the knee touches the ground and as his
knee touches the ground,
you're opponent is already launching
into a knee,
a counter nate,
which is the perfect technique for that
position,
right?
What happens there should be,
is that illegal?
It should be.
If someone shoots a total power double
on you.
And as they're sliding in their knees,
hitting the ground and you catch them
with a knee and put them out.
Is that a need or grounded opponent?
I mean,
how does that work?
Well,
he slipped in.
I would say that's the same as I hit
you,
but you turn your head at the moment.
I hit you.
I hit the back of your head.
Who are gaming the system?
Remember when the guys would.
They would just put that they have they.
Yeah,
that was just a little.
But,
but it's also like there was a
controversial fight really recently with
um,
uh,
Oliveira's and a 10 means tim and Tim
means and Mark Ratner,
we,
I asked him when it was,
he's only on one point at one point
being one knee.
I guess foot wasn't even on the ground
like,
and his other foot was up.
Something like,
is that legal?
Like it was real confusing,
confusing run.
Mark Ratner said it should be legal.
And I'm like,
okay,
well it's one point is illegal.
And then John Macarthur said,
no.
He said it's not a point.
He said like that,
that expression that everybody uses
three points more than three points,
like two hands and two feet rather than
a hand.
It's illegal to hit person when they're
down,
but he says it's the bottom of your
feet.
Anytime it's not the bottom of your feet
are grounded opponent.
So even if you have one knee on the
ground and no feet like you're,
you're just bouncing and moving towards,
you're still a grounded opponent.
Yeah.
Which is weird.
That's weird.
I'm not sure if I agree with that.
No,
I don't either.
And and niche to the opponent on the
grunt,
I always scraped her knee.
I think it's better then elbows and
nowadays we see some knockouts with
elbows and there's a lot of cuts and
then you know,
and you don't have to with the knee and
evil.
Well,
no.
So that's why I said it's easy.
It's an easy defense once you know what
going to be coming there.
It's a bigger thing.
You can just hold the thigh.
I mean,
but it's.
I prefer it over lotion.
Do you remember when Coleman used it and
pride from Randall Road South position?
Well,
Ya know,
those are just,
I mean from sky high or just right to
the.
I mean it's a restaurant.
One of the rest of the process moves
because the wrestler,
they'll,
you know,
if you're trying to shoot on them and
they sprawl and they're on top that they
have those needs right there.
Boom,
boom.
It's
a tremendous technique for wrestlers.
Remember Coleman?
That was the beginning.
The arms did it to Maurice.
Maurice Smith.
Mark Coleman.
Fight with when headbutts were allowed.
People forget that was nuts.
But is it,
is it so nuts?
Why can't your head.
But I just like how come you can use
your elbow but you can't head.
But why can't you art nine lymph node,
right?
I mean if you can cut someone with
elbows,
right?
You're slashing across their face with
elbows.
Why can't you have.
But because of the concussion thing,
I don't know,
but it's up to you.
Right?
I mean it seems like we were talking
about the art of actual fighting.
Sure.
We know that a headbutt is a real
martial arts technique.
Yep.
You know,
I know why that is.
And it was one of the reasons I would
have bought somebody if there was a lot
of audience,
uh,
when I was fighting at a club,
if I had to fight,
almost never fought for what you do
because I just talked my way out though.
I would tell the people that you just
nothing going on.
But if I did,
I used it on purpose headbutts because
they look really insane and I will make
sure that older people were watching
that they would understand that,
you know,
we can't accept that kind of behavior
that have bought,
that will freak people out,
you know?
And I truly believe that's it's for,
you know,
for the sport to make the sport more
attractive.
Take the hell wants a normal person,
watches the fight,
like a comas thought,
headbutting somebody into oblivion,
you know,
they're going to go,
is this a sport?
It looks,
it looks really bad.
It looks terrible.
So to soccer kid.
So I was going to say ground and pound
for that matter.
A lot of boxes and people had a hard
time with people being on the ground and
getting hammered.
Interested in the big problem.
Once you're aware,
tell you remember if they won the
championship.
That was scary.
I mean,
I don't know why the referee didn't stop
the why he let him kick.
I mean it was obvious he was.
He was an a la La land use in Lala land
and he got hit with the horrible soccer
kick in.
His whole body went flying.
He was just dead out cold.
Could have killed him.
Well,
and you know Rogers and a guy that
should have been a superstar man cover
of sports.
There's a curse.
The curse,
the curse.
He fell right into it and he's on the
cover.
Curse somebody thing.
But athletes so mad and curse,
the curse type thing.
But that's also what they said about the
UFC game.
Cop gets on it.
It is weird,
crazy urban legend.
The states that individuals and teams
who appeared on the cover of sports
illustrated magazine will subsequently
be jinx.
Well,
it does it say anything in terms of what
actual a result.
How many pots.
Look,
there's touch folks.
I couldn't even read this list.
This list is fucking.
It's
like everybody would ever to.
You don't want to be on it.
I believe we didn't think.
Was that before the fight?
Before the fight.
Conor mcgregor.
March fifth,
2016.
Holy Shit.
Go West side.
Jake's.
He was scheduled to fight how us on
Joseph.
Then dos Anjos fell apart with a broken
foot.
Dos Anjos is going up to me to a
welterweight.
That's interesting.
Very interesting.
I love how he,
how he feels good without uh,
cutting so much weight.
He's a big fella.
Everybody.
Everybody when they fight they fight so
much better.
But then whoever.
Does everyone do that?
I think yeah.
For,
for a lot of reasons.
You should fight closer to a solution.
Do you think there's a way that they can
make guys way their natural weight?
Like test them the same way they test
for like drugs?
Test them for hydration.
Like show up.
Hey Maura,
we're going to just put you on a scale
today and find out what you actually
will moral you.
Fight 1:55.
You weigh one 86.
What the fuck's going on dude?
Yeah man.
Get in shape.
Get in shape and tell us when you're
ready and what you actually weigh.
And so then when you find out that the
guys in shape and you're actually,
you go your,
your,
your shape,
you're in,
you're ready.
Okay?
Okay,
well it says here you weigh one 75.
There you go.
Okay,
now we're going to check your hydration
levels.
Oh,
well you're dehydrated though.
Okay.
We're going to get you to the normal
hydration level.
This is argued.
Now you're healthy.
You're one 79.
Okay?
This is what you weigh.
One hundred 80 pound fighter.
Yup.
And just decide whether or not you want
to fight.
And if you do,
this is what you fight at.
Or if you want to weigh less,
you got to have to lose some weight,
but you can prove that you actually way
that you know,
like lose all the body fat.
Get yourself to a good position.
You know?
Okay,
so what are you at now?
You're at will?
I've got myself down to one 70 way.
I'm okay.
Looks like you're actually one 70 and
look,
check your hydration.
Your healthy.
Okay.
So this is your real weight.
You fight one 70.
Perfect.
I mean how many guys?
My weight class of course,
and that's unfortunate,
but for the goiter was established for
the greater good.
I like that you said it already at the
beginning of the old ways.
They blame other people.
Fighters,
you know,
and if there's nobody to blame,
they blame the fact that their opponent
was cutting more weight so he was
stronger in the fight.
That's why I lost.
No,
you lost because you lost.
You didn't lose because she weighed five
pounds.
Sex.
I look at the old days,
man,
let's forget what Frankie.
He,
everybody will.
You just won 55.
18.
He didn't cut a goddamn out one and he's
beating everybody.
But that's,
that's,
that's the problem.
And they got and they shocked for
focusing on it and at least because they
can give it a reason.
And then let's hope that the main
events,
we've lost shows and we will lose sight.
Chris Justino,
I mean,
what is her weight?
What is the most healthiest?
She's think that's true.
That's true.
So Bonnie,
she's bigger than that.
I agree with you.
I don't think if she,
if it's that much of a struggle,
she's almost done outside of to make
1:40
1:45
is a bruised street with 1:50
5:55
is a real weight class.
There you go.
So,
well maybe it's not for her,
but you know,
I'm hearing that she's even heavier than
one 75.
She's way over one 80 shift.
Gabby.
Gabby slows down their friends.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean I've,
I wish there were more weight classes
for men and for women.
You know,
I wish there was a ton of weight classes
in boxing.
I think.
Yeah.
The one thing that boxing has the people
don't like is that they have so many
champions.
You have too many weight classes,
but that's how you make things fair.
You're right,
you've got like you can't have a one 85
and then a two.
Oh five.
That jump is huge.
Twenty five to 65,
20 stakes,
20 pounds.
Take Twenty one ounce or 16 ounce t bone
steak and stack them up and imagine that
someone has that advantage over you.
If it's in his belly,
it's okay to 35 week class,
we need that.
I think you're right.
Or 2:25,
25 maybe at 2:45
and then unlimited.
You know,
who knows,
but I think that having heavyweight
where there's a weightless,
you can't weigh more than two 65.
That seems crazy because they had a been
what?
80 a day of the fight will look and then
you're struggling.
You can,
you can go to two.
Oh five to 20 and you have a really hard
gut and then you face a guy who's do 85.
Although the early morning thing I guess
has been successful right?
The day of the.
Now it's successful.
Radically unsuccessful.
There's been 17 different people missing
weight like one or two in the same time.
So then what's this?
Why is that then just because they want
to get the edge,
the safety,
safety,
it gives people more time to rehydrate
themselves,
but the problem is it gives them less
time to lose the weight.
Right?
So if you're starting off early in the
morning,
like if you're,
if your weigh ins or at 4:00
and you know you're not going to eat all
day,
you're going to lose weight all
throughout the day,
but if you're way answered at 8:00
in the morning when you're getting up,
you're going to lose all that weight.
You know,
you might not,
you might not lose enough weight.
So people were miscalculating including.
There's definitely a lot.
There's definitely an issue with people
cutting too much weight.
doing it unhealthy Sunday be punished or
penalized even more though,
like I just recently heard Gospel 30
percent of his wealth and that's what,
okay,
that,
that's fine.
But even Calvin Gospel when they admit,
yeah,
I haven't really been looking after my
died.
Right.
You're a professional athlete signed to
the.
The biggest organization in the world
did.
Shouldn't that be part of the contract
that in if you're fighting for us that
you have to maintain,
you almost have those.
I instead of even a random drug tests,
random random way to obviously they made
calvin go up to one 85.
Yes.
Next fight.
And what's crazy is he looked fucking
insane and Tim Kennedy blew his entire,
was trying to take him down and beat him
up.
And the earlier,
the first round,
I mean,
he,
he showed his size advantage,
his strength advantage.
He's a massive,
uh,
like he's
a massive powerhouse when it comes to
his ground and pound his Jujitsu.
But Calvin just stayed the course,
the defense.
And then eventually when he got on his
feet,
man way to swift and it's,
how many times does he know?
Three just missed a bunch of times he
missed against Tyron Woodley and tyron
and beat him.
And tyrone as a gentleman,
decided yes,
even take his money.
Remember the which is a very fucking
ethical and moral move by the champ.
Now the current champ.
So he lost that.
And I mean there was more than one fight
in the past for that.
But you wouldn't,
you say.
Okay.
Again,
not because he's a great fighter,
like you're saying.
Very good.
One 85.
So let's hope.
Okay.
Stays.
But if Mrs Wade,
you should take a year.
You can,
you know,
put the fear in them and then they
really going to do.
I think Calvin should fight at 85.
I think he could when he could.
When it 70.
I think he can make 70 but he doesn't
always make sense or you're right one.
Yeah,
I mean unless he wants to lose a ton of
body fat and then try fighting at one
70,
you know,
really clean his diet up.
Really go down the bricks.
Donnie Henderson does not seem like the
same person.
Oh what it.
Because of Thompson wrecking them the
way.
But I agree because I heard you say as
well,
even though like physically did not look
physically.
No,
he doesn't look like he works as hard.
It doesn't look like he is as motivated.
He doesn't look as hungry.
His vaunted knockout power is gone.
Gone,
gone.
Great.
Weird,
it's weird.
Yeah,
I,
I wanted him and I said a long time ago
if I was just coaching with his tie his
left hand through his body and it put
them after every workout.
You go three or four rounds on the back,
you know,
just using your right hand Kale.
Imagine if he developed a right hand on
top of that.
I mean because it was 90 percent was
left,
you know,
you would,
that you open a whole new door,
you know,
and it's an unfair to question someone
whether or not they tested positive for
anything.
If they took anything,
if you haven't tested positive.
So he never tested positive for
anything.
So you can't look at it that I don't
think he did.
Did he know maybe a diuretic or
something.
Maybe.
Maybe find out if Johnny Hendricks ever
tested positive for something.
I don't think he did.
So you know,
there's a lot of people throwing
accusations about him and George St
Pierre was.
But you know what it costs will be one
of the things he said about his last
fight,
he said he worked out four times a week,
week one time,
four times a week.
He's like,
he just was not focused on that fight.
If that's the case,
you've got to get.
That's why he looks like that has
nothing to do with Usada or anything
else.
He just doesn't have the hunger.
And that's it.
And that's where you,
you put yourself at great risk,
but also mentally going into the fight.
If you know that another guy trained 10
times a week and you're trained for what
are you going to do it for?
It's just weird that his power went
away.
I mean he used to make ice crumble.
He used to let me know when he hit John
Fitch and went flying,
Martin Kampmann flying,
went flying.
It was like he had magic in his hands
and then all of a sudden it stopped.
So what the fuck really just ruined him.
Yeah,
he.
Yeah.
And you fucked him up and he fucked him
up with like using that front leg side
kick.
And then the front leg round kiss would
he hit a bad one to the body and then
johnny leg nods his head like you got
me.
And then slap the same one right up to
the face.
And that's the thing with water boy,
he makes it.
Oh yeah.
Perfectly.
And then it suddenly a hook a get a
question mark and it's every time it's a
different cake,
you don't know what's going to come.
Mr Berger Talk Shit about him.
All the spinning kicks.
It's a waste of energy.
So.
Oh,
for real.
This shit out.
I don't think it's a coincidence city.
We'll kicked ellenberger in the head
twice.
Here's your waste of time,
dude.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not a waste.
It's some fucking super good at this.
But Greg King,
conor Mcgregor too,
right?
He's using a lot more.
But the kitchen like him during the more
to measure the whole the opponent at bay
and then suddenly his his hand.
So the left turn lane.
The Guy Man,
he's one of my favorite guys to watch.
Also be outside of fighting.
Get the way he talks.
He never has the same like with me with
interviews where people ask,
you know about your life,
how it started.
Well,
it,
it's,
it's the same story over and over again.
Well,
he can.
He can make it every time.
He's one of those guys that constantly
changes.
Smart businessman.
Oh,
smart.
Smart is.
He's the best shit talker in the history
of combat sports.
Before that it was chill son into
Mohammed Ali and now it's conor
mcgregor.
He just knows how to fucking say it.
Jeremy Stevens starts talking to him.
He goes,
the guy just destroyed them with one
sentence.
I mean,
it's,
he's,
he finds the perfect shit.
You say.
The way he looked back.
It's hilarious when he went in there and
dilated Eddie Alvarez like that.
You just gotta go,
fuck man.
He's any of that style of sliding out
and sliding in.
It's a very unusual,
almost a karate based style with like
sitting down on vicious punches on the
end of it,
you know,
but you don't hit stamps and because
she's a soccer ball.
But I,
I thought,
you know what,
with the.
Although if I was all those coach a year
ago already,
I would have said when we go to trey
South Pole and you because there's no
way he can block those low kicks if
left,
there's no way he can block them because
his stance is too white and his knees
are pointing to the again,
100 percent.
The whole game changes the whole game
and his left low kick by the way.
Look.
Although could kick the fuck out of you
with either low or right.
Wow Man.
Yeah.
He,
he,
he made me think of for Ramon dekkers,
Ya know,
that explosive.
Oh Man.
His law will.
They call the Duchy left to the body and
then right leg kicked behind it.
Chad Mendez.
I was like,
whoa.
Though he throws it man.
I think although and Max Holloway's have
very interesting fight that fight.
So it has to.
It has happen.
I keep hearing all this crazy shit like
Aldo my go up and fight a bead for the
interim title and I'm like,
God damn it.
You got to have a fight at 12.
There we go again.
Right.
The money you weight fights,
everyone already even talked about
mcwane instead of staying in their way
instead of defending the title they own.
I mean it's obviously not as big a fight
is him fighting Nijmegen madoff in
Russia.
Right.
And especially if they fight for a 55
pound title,
they've never gone out fights in Russia
and they might have to fucking build a
new soccer stadium.
I don't think people understand.
Anytime I post something on Instagram,
I get 150 fucking Russian dudes who
write Habib time and then they just
pulled her beep time with the credit
side.
My fucking credits are overrun with
people that say aura,
not credits,
comments.
Overrun with people say Habib time,
Habib time.
Fucking just for safety.
When they're building that thing,
make an underground tunnel for when he
loses his straight to the airport.
Like if you fight conor.
You know what's interesting about the
conor fight,
man,
lack Habib time.
Habib time.
See?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's not fucking around.
It's all true.
But like,
um,
if he fights connor,
we,
Michael Johnson cracked him and rocked
him.
I went,
oh boy,
he did get angry and he beat the fuck
out of them,
but the point is he got hurt,
he got hurt,
and if connor catches you like that,
you might be fucking Donesville.
He might drop some hammers on you and
that might be the same thing.
Right.
The we've seen caught her as well at
times.
It's just the bet habibs defense.
We saw conor get rocked against nate and
you wind up losing that fight.
Shortly thereafter Habib got rocked and
it's Michael Johnson came back stronger.
Yeah,
dominated him.
So it was the only time.
I mean,
it's when you see a guy with his
dominant is a Habib,
you start looking for weaknesses in his
arm.
It's the only time we've seen any
weakness at all.
But uh,
Greg,
in his defense,
he was getting tired already there.
Yup.
Yup,
sure.
Would that be.
Doesn't get tired.
Did you see that funny video to habit to
narrating guy who's constantly dropping
f bombs leftover?
I tell a story about how bp they always
training and where you coach from,
no one was six years old.
He was already wrestling with fricking
bears and it's really funny.
It's.
It's on here right now somewhere.
Do you know what the name of the show?
A hobby.
A Hobby Promo.
Just put that on trusting man of the
world title.
It's lately made so it will pop up and
pop.
I guess it's really funny.
Nice.
And you see them wrestling a bear.
A bear when he was six years old and
then he starts talking about his father
who was already a really.
But that's the other thing.
Judo Guy MMA and sample reports.
The memes.
The use of social media get so cool man.
Well the.
Unless you Ronda Rousey's Nunez fight or
should come in so many fucking people.
You know what those mean?
What do you,
what do you think she's coming back?
No,
I don't think she.
I mean
I don't think.
I don't think if she does,
she should come back in a calculated
manner.
Like don't just rush in and fight for
the title like she did.
I think that's crazy.
Taking a year off,
getting head kick,
knocked out,
you know?
Where's your head out?
And was she 100 percent committed to
this as far as like training for the
entire time off?
Or did she just get in really good shape
over the last few months and had she
been training at all before then?
I mean,
you'd have to ask her and answer all
those questions,
but if she doesn't want to be fighting,
she shouldn't be fighting,
you know,
but you know from the beginning of
movement head movement.
So I assumed they worked on the hand
movement.
I just think the pressure and the way
she comes to the angry phase and all
that shuts her down and,
and you know,
it's still much pressure.
A whole Hollywood career writes on it.
I mean that's not gonna happen now,
right?
I mean,
because buddy was a tool.
We talked about no footwork,
no defense thing,
but that's what nurses can do to you.
I would like to see a Rhonda with a
smile on her face,
go tutoring,
being relaxed and calm,
send her away,
go to a Duane Ludwig for a year and have
some smokers because she can still
legally do that.
And other clubs.
Just striking,
you know,
to,
to just get in that moment that to see
where you went.
I think in training,
this is the problem that everybody has,
you know,
in training,
you always do good.
A lot of guys do good,
but you know as well as I do that as
these gym guys are really good in
training,
they can do it on a pressure.
So if she's been boxing and working on a
striking and she's been hitting people
left,
they're right there.
They got some good people coming in.
I heard that she works out even with
boxing champions are champions and doing
well against this.
But then again,
you know that that's a nice safe
environment.
Bringing it under pressure with all the
crap she had on her shoulders.
I thought it's also takes it away.
New is a very,
very dangerous punch.
Sod In strikeforce kicks right away,
her kicks or punches and kicks and
punches so fucking hard and she has long
arms man and she puts you on the end of
these long punches and cheat.
Dinged Rhonda very early in the fight
and you could tell she was rock.
She goes right back into the whole
fight.
That's what I think happened.
And,
and Nunez also leans all the way over,
so it's hard to take her down,
you know,
and run.
That should also,
you know,
and maybe she's doing it,
I'm just saying what I don't see,
you know,
maybe stock wrestling over a small intel
because a girl like that,
but so much talent,
she'll pick that up so fast.
But if she suddenly suits for a singer
or don't,
but she'd already been rock.
So I think that because remember she's
shocked her off clenches.
Yeah,
his upper body couch and she always
reaches him with the left arm.
It's like this,
you know Greg Jackson,
I talked about it after the Holly Holm
fight that they had seen every single
one of her fights.
She comes at you,
she got that left arm,
extended,
tries to get ahold of girls with left
arm hip,
tosses them,
gets them on the ground,
armbars on.
And they just were.
So
that was going to say,
interesting that home shifting from mma,
from boxing Dema just trained for Ronda
Rousey fight.
Cody car brand.
Remember Shit as a kickboxing,
kickboxing,
and boxing champ,
but I'm saying in terms of our MMA prep,
the goal was Ronda Rousey right
and now with cody garbrandt he talked
about in high school,
Dominick Cruz.
And you think you wonder,
well,
the,
the laser focus,
right?
The television,
obviously you have to work on
everything,
but if that's your target and you see
what he did to cruise it,
well there's a lot of fighters like that
that attract greatness.
Like I think Anderson Silva attracted
greatness and I think one of the reasons
why Weidman became as great as he was
because he knew that Anderson Silva was
at the top of the mountain.
Can you see that?
That,
that assassin,
you know,
and Weidman caught him like right at the
right time and you know,
knocked them out and then the broken leg
and the second fight and it.
I think when you have a dominant
champion like Anderson was for so many
years,
all those young kids coming up,
that's who they aspire to and raises the
bar like I want.
I'm really curious to see what the
flyweights look like in a few years.
Yes.
Because of how good mighty mouse is
because his bar,
he's raised it so it's way above
everybody else.
But yeah,
but,
uh,
you know,
and associate for getting to coastal
planning for two feet next to each
other,
having no for backwards site and we'll
let her will move with whatsoever you
can only lean as much backwards.
Right for that left hook he received
from Weipa and well,
you know,
when he fought Weidman,
it had a very clever move that a lot of
people missed.
And what he did was he threw a right
hand and then behind the right hand
threw,
he threw a back fist so there was a,
a punch coming from the left and then he
moved towards it and another punch
coming towards left because it was a
left hook because the Anderson is doing
is bobbing and weaving stuff.
But when a punch comes out,
um,
and then a backfill,
he's got to go that way up.
So then he's got to go that way.
So when he went back,
right,
that's when Chris Weidman cracked him
with that long left.
That's the same punch that he used to
knock out your rial hall.
He throws this long straight armed hook
and it's very deceiving how much
distance you can cover with it,
you know?
Yeah.
A lot of distance.
Plus it sent straight spot.
Straight punches are better as well.
I always say,
you know,
that's why I always liked to use
clotheslines.
Yeah,
I mean you have more reach.
If you connect with a left hook,
you'll wait to see if the person doesn't
move your weight,
your close for a straight punch.
But if you make it a palm strike,
now we have some space that we can
cover.
What did you think a Yoel Romero
knocking out Weidman was not insane.
Why did,
why did white men even wanted to go for
that?
I mean,
he had the whole training camp.
He said,
I don't what she said,
I have no clue.
I did it because we,
we knew we should not do that.
And as soon as she lowered himself,
it was.
Yeah,
it just glided.
There's just a perfect knee because he
was doing freaking awesome.
We did exactly what I said in the game
plan,
and you'll go,
go,
go.
It doesn't matter if he keep him down,
take him.
They'll get all those muscles working.
I'm trying to get them tired.
Uh,
and it was working for him until you're
well decided to wrestle with them.
And then he was thrown Weidman around
that second round.
That's when you realize how strong a
wrestler he is,
how good his wrestling.
Another saying,
the wrestling of the high level,
Olympic caliber and get our to dangerous
dudes.
That's why he's the freak of all free
stands next to all of them.
It just looks like what in the fuck did
they feed you in Cuba?
But the same thing with him.
Can you imagine if he starts focusing
on the right side a little bit more?
What a super freaked his guy is going to
be because all those attacks are coming
to left leg,
left knee,
left straight,
pretty much the only way time when he
uses the right look,
he gets to set up a straight punch or
kick or whatever.
And he doesn't throw with power,
you should counter that,
that right kick that distros outside
lack or inside leg,
whatever statute.
But you should counter that instantly
because otherwise the big hand is going
to come.
But if he starts developing a right and
a right kick,
just do things so right near right who,
whatever he is,
he too muscular and I know it's late for
you.
But that's what I'm saying.
But it's like
you look at a guy like that because you
save physical specimen man,
just so incredibly,
uh,
above and beyond,
but yet,
okay,
it's working for him while he's humble
Johnson.
Yep.
So it's definitely not a problem.
It just has to manage it.
Like in a lot of ways,
the same way tyron woodley uses his
power.
He's obviously much more muscular,
much stronger than most guys in that
division.
And he showed the wonderboy fight,
the Woodley knows how to manage it.
And I came out,
he went full five rounds.
And what's really important is that he
stunned wonderboy and the fourth.
So they're in the championship round,
still rocked him and hurt him bad and
had them in deep,
deep trouble.
So I feel like there's so many benefits
to being as powerful as Yellow Romero
is.
There's definitely a downside.
The downside is if a guy like Weidman
didn't shoot for that and was constantly
wearing on him,
constantly grinding on him and had him
in a bit of trouble,
like Tim Kennedy had been his second
round,
then you know,
we'll see what happens.
It hasn't happened yet.
I mean even in the Kennedy fight,
he definitely cheated.
Right.
You definitely saw that and,
and he was tired,
but they still at knockout power,
he's still recovering.
I still came back to fuck Kennedy and it
was like,
Jesus Christ,
he's such a monster.
He's so.
He's so much better of an athlete than
almost anybody else in the division.
When he throws guys around,
he just,
they could just go sailing.
Or guys who.
I've always been impressed with a guy
who mean the guy with the striking to me
and he well fucked him up to hit him
with that spinning back fist and hit
them all.
All hurt.
Came back from that fight in one good
thoroughbreds mare.
A lot of great fights and what know know
Yoel Romero one,
he wanted the decision but the cision
was overturned because of the drug.
So yeah,
he had some sort of peptides that they
found in the supplement that he was
taking.
So they only gave him like a nine month
suspension was Saint Joe's took
for understanding.
That's why I don't watch to me was like,
that was kind of weird because he is
managed by.
No,
definitely not.
Okay.
I thought that.
No,
no,
no.
He had some growth hormone thing inside
of it.
Whereas Jones had clomifene.
Clomifene is,
uh,
an estrogen suppressor that people use,
kickstart their testosterone production
after a steroid cycle.
It's an extra burden.
Estrogen rather,
um,
suppressing the first one who brought
actually the product that he says,
this is what I looked into it and that's
what I never.
I always said that the older fighters
say,
but nobody,
if I would be,
the guy would say this is what it took
police test is,
and he said,
are you a proponent like cut?
A lot of people say why?
What do supplements actually do for the
the,
the athlete if this is what's been
happening with attendance where you get
your supplements from there.
The real issue with supplements is some
of them definitely work,
you know,
I mean,
how much should you be allowed to
enhance your body with nutritional
supplements?
Right?
Because there's a lot of supplements at
work.
Creatine works is a lot of stuff that
works,
so you have to figure out like,
okay,
well how much can it work?
You know,
it obviously can't work like Andrew on
or all those hormone precursors that
they've all band.
Okay,
well it can't work that good.
Can it work as good as this?
And then like there's all these
different,
you know,
standards.
I mean there's,
there's certain protocols that people
follow when ti comes of it turns to have
a vitamin replacements and they do ivy
vitamin drips and extreme concentration
on their nutrition and they have
results.
Those results,
they,
they tend to show that there are
benefits in supplementation and there's
definitely benefits and clean diet and
making sure that your nutritional
balances.
So like at what level should it be
illegal?
You know what I mean?
You can't.
How you found the fuck.
Are you getting so much?
Be Twelve out of nature.
They're not.
You have to take it in a pill.
Then it gives you energy.
Well what the fuck is that?
And you could take some caffeine like
Chael Sonnen,
he used to take caffeine pills to make
sure that he got the exact amount of
caffeine because he's like,
you don't know because you get a
starbucks,
you might get a Venti starbucks and they
might've fucking packed it in tight and
chews the shit out of it and you can get
a cup of coffee like coffee.
So it might actually test over.
So in order to make sure that jail was
in the the lines,
he would take pills.
Caffeine is illegal.
It's sort of lifts legal.
Illegal.
Yeah.
But if you get to a certain number,
it's illegal.
Okay.
If you get past a certain amount of
milligrams in your system,
I don't know how they mentioned that.
That's the other thing that
testosterone,
deputy testosterone or talk to medical
professionals and everyone saying men
you produce supposed to be around one
took one.
That's all.
Yeah.
Unless you're some weird freak,
you might be like one to two.
Okay.
So four to one or six to one.
How does that,
you know,
that's always been.
What about is wanting to learn and for
injury recovery,
Joe and I know a lot of people.
Fighters.
That's what they said.
Well Geez,
I had a mortgage.
I have to fight.
I got to support the family.
Is there a way to monitor that where
even though the band steroid thing where
you can allow a person to at least make
a living without making it an
enhancement?
Well,
it's going to be an enhancement.
That's the problem right away.
When is he going to be an enhancement,
but if you take steroids while you're
like say if you have a knee surgery and
then he takes steroids and then you're
lifting weights the entire time,
so you're going to keep some of those
games,
you're going to keep a certain
percentage of it,
but on the flip side,
your endocrine system is going to be
fucked up and it's going to take you a
while to get back to normal testosterone
production.
If you do end up testing and you do go
back on Usada after the injury.
So there's an argument so that you're
taking a risk,
you do recover quicker,
but it might not be better for your
overall hormone system.
Right?
You know,
I remember I was talking about it,
we did it on the podcast.
I don't,
I don't memorize have it memorized,
but there was a test but testosterone,
what they did in the Olympics,
Bri,
uh,
steroids and after steroids and they
start really testing biological passport
and they say that it actually did not
help that more people who didn't use had
better results than the people who were
using.
And it was same thing as me.
I get that face,
what you have now,
two analysts,
but uh,
you know,
I'll look it up and you know what I'm
saying,
whenever the Russians are doing whatever
they're doing to do it because they got
a fucking state sponsored program,
you know,
United States is working hard to try to
clean it up.
I mean they have baseball players have
to go in front of Congress.
They arrest people,
people getting locked up.
You saw to jeff and Wicki cron up
everybody's ass.
We're trying to find people that are
still steerer using steroids and
cheating and Russia now like,
what are we going to like?
Candy?
Let's fucking make it happen.
You need to be faster.
The stuff that I got from a horse,
stick it inside your body and see if you
become a horse.
Crazy tests in the early days.
Also we'd like making super soldiers in
injecting people with like plutonium,
like a live person.
This is what happened.
If he'd like the freaking Wolf Hall and
they watched so many comic books.
I mean they,
they almost kicked the entire Russian
Olympics the Olympics.
The Olympics in Brazil,
they were like,
Hey,
what the fuck?
At the last minute they decided not to,
but they've been going back,
you know,
they use the old samples from 2008 and
12 and they've already kicked out to a
Russian Olympic gold medalists in
wrestling.
They were on the shit.
They're on the shit that just on this
undetectable shit or some shit that they
don't detect yet.
Which of course,
and when you see him.
Oh yeah.
I mean lifting straight from you,
like the sport.
Is it ever going to be clean?
Well,
it's way cleaner now in the UFC that
it's ever been before,
but I think there's also.
I liked the fact that one fcs available
for guys who don't want to be clean.
Yeah.
Risings available for guys who don't
want to be clean.
You know,
there's an argument either way,
there's an argument for the pride way,
which was everybody knew that everybody
was on it.
Tested pride.
Right.
Hey boss,
what's this?
Why is this a viable?
Just civic here.
I mean,
buddy,
I did this thing believable decoder,
the boss to her.
I was going backstage with the camera
showing everybody,
hey man,
what's up here?
You don't look there spending training
and you know,
and then I say okay,
we walk into the room from the doctors.
So I opened the door and I looked at the
side and I see all the protests there
with little sticks on them.
Right.
And I closed the door right away to look
into camera.
I said,
give me one moment to the very busy,
let me walk in and ask for permission.
So I walk in and I grabbed one of those
cups and I see green tea or fill it up
and it put the same cup next to it.
So then when you weren't even allowed to
be that close.
So yeah,
yeah,
she,
I could have contaminated everything.
So I'm walking in and I'm saying,
oh,
these had a doctors here and they looked
at us and go,
Oh hey,
the tests.
I said,
man,
wouldn't it be great if you can taste
what fighter it is?
And these people,
they looked at me and so I take my green
tea
and I take the thing off.
And they go like,
no,
take a little sip.
And I said,
I go
coleman or freaking gold.
There was a clear illustration,
obviously.
Serious.
Yeah,
not water,
you know,
it's been real open about it and talked
about like they literally said in large
prints,
we do not test you forest
thing,
you know,
I,
I knew a guy from there and he would say
to me that in the morning he would take
a huge runs of
testosterone because it made him really
angry in the morning.
That jacked up once far.
And Andy,
what about these guys who were like
bench pressing the day before,
you know,
all these muscles
guy.
So when they got in,
you know that you have the white dude.
I have these guys because of the
cosmetic thing.
Pride would love to the freaks,
my man.
And that's a,
you know,
a lot of matchmaking
guys.
Remember Jason Chambers from,
he went over to Japan,
I forget which organization was that?
They,
they want him to fight one 85 and he's
like,
wait one 70.
And they're like,
don't worry,
we'll get you on this title.
He wanted him to juice up and go to one
85.
And he was like,
what in the fuck?
That's the problem.
You know what?
But people say he,
they say they should just allow it.
I say yeah,
but then you force the guys who want to
stay clean to use it as well.
And you shouldn't.
Joel mentioned earlier,
I mean the health,
there are health risks risks,
but I think not even health risks,
I think it doesn't damage your,
your
system when you do steroids.
Well it depends on how much you're
doing,
but if you're,
if you're going like super hyper human
levels,
like I'm sure a lot of those guys were a
yes for you.
And it's one of the real clear
indicators that a lot of guys were on it
were how they got off of it and came to
the UFC and looked like models.
They look like cumin pitbulls right away
with a lot of them.
Yeah.
I'm a lot of them.
I mean,
it's just,
it is what it is and it's a.
unfortunately the early roots of mma
were marred like it's,
it's almost all people that took
steroids.
I mean,
there's so many camps.
If you talked to the insiders,
they will tell,
God dammit,
back then everybody was on,
everybody was on,
you know,
and you don't have to name names and
everybody who knows knows and it doesn't
matter,
but what does matter is that when you
look at the early days of the sport,
it was insane,
essentially contaminated and now they've
wiped out a giant percentage of it and
occasionally guys still get caught with
some things and you know,
Cyborg got caught with a,
some sort of quick.
Yeah.
That's also spironolactone is also a dht
inhibitor.
It's dihydrotestosterone,
which is a derivative of testosterone
which makes your hair fall out and I
used to use that spironolactone stuff
that she got caught with.
I used to rub that shit in my head to
keep my hair from falling out.
Yeah,
boss.
I'm taking notes.
I feel like I'm studying under professor
Rogan right now.
This is amazing,
but
it's also used by people who want to
shield themselves from tests.
It's also used by females that have
taken male hormones and they want to
reduce the effects of the extra
androgens.
Yeah,
so there's a lot of.
A lot of factors.
Yeah.
Once they start growing hair,
I think,
and getting all this,
we would see guys come in just that you
can tell right away,
Bang.
A chick and you see Werewolf back here.
Well,
they say to us can be as big as a thumb.
Right?
That's what they say though.
Yours.
My girth is less like pop sap bad.
The worst story.
I've heard some guy I was talking,
I'm not gonna mention names and he said,
and we were talking about that at a.
I go,
uh Oh man.
That's got to be.
That's got to be really horrible.
Oh No.
I had one.
I did a body builder and then she had
like a big thing I do.
What did you do?
He said,
oh,
I shucked it.
Isn't that funny?
Look,
we're all good with sucking clip.
As long as they're little little,
but I don't care if it feels good for
you,
if it's.
If I feel it more than a half an inch
into my mouth is on fire,
even though it's a woman's vagina,
but if it comes with the accompanied
voice,
the dark voice,
when you do a Netflix special,
a good tourist back here,
I'm not dying motherfucker.
You are going to be by far the fathers.
There's got to be guys who are just
really into being dominated by super
powerful women with big cliffs kind of
people.
Yup,
Yup.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Some guys are listening right now.
Go.
Oh yeah.
That's my stuff.
Do you
think that when you guys look at rise
and right now,
do you think the rise in has the
possibility of coming here,
putting on some fucking big shows.
They've got some good fights,
you know,
cro,
cop,
just ones that heavyweight tournament,
you know,
you're shaking your head over there.
I think they have a of success.
It's hard to do.
Again.
They go to neat after Sakharova stopped
pride,
parade much went to start going to a
star.
That's the thing.
Exactly.
You know,
you have seen it with the gay one.
That was the reason [inaudible] stopped
at certain time.
There was no more Japanese star and they
need a good one or a fight is going to
beat for Gracie's right there.
That's something that's,
that's a one in a lifetime deal.
What came Masato and the lighter weight
was a superstar.
He will mix.
Yeah,
I came one Max,
but then we'll get up to your bigger
guys when to,
once you get a guy like potter Hari
size,
it's just not who the fuck is going to
be that big,
you know,
how that fight in her heart and rico
very climactic but broke his arm but
still interesting fight what was going
on and I'm excited about a rematch.
So he might be wanting to come back as
well.
And a boy.
Yes.
But against 40.
Right.
These guys are.
I just met the Madison Square Garden for
the,
uh,
for the wheelchairs.
The fighting a December 31st Monday.
Was there his trainer when you're on
skis and uh,
but he,
he didn't say anything.
He,
he sat,
you know that actually I met the guy who
remembers champions.
He sat and he said [inaudible],
but he didn't say anything more.
Seventy shelter to retire because of the
heart conditions.
Are those by de?
Yeah,
it's.
So you see if a guy like uber,
uhm,
like back when he was ubering and when
he was winning one 65 super jacked and
then he goes to mma.
But you know,
Guy Wins The k Grand Prix.
Like you gotta wonder like a guy like
ubereats,
if he came back as ubereats,
you know,
like I don't know if its glory or Bella
tour,
whoever,
whoever has got the stones in the cash
to pull them aside and said,
listen fella as work to be done here.
Yes you can.
They would love to do it.
The Diet that the horse meat,
this is my friend.
He's from another country and he is a
doctor.
She will help you.
They will make you better,
stronger,
faster.
Comes back again,
man.
Back when he knocked out,
bought her daughter with a complete
animal.
Belong.
I want to see him.
That night I broke down.
That was the one time in all the fights
and everything we've seen and I remember
I was there,
wouldn't have Jose,
a pelly and John,
so it gets Brian gasaway in Canada.
John Mccarthy and I broke his leg,
but for some reason,
Saki and Spong,
I was broke down just to see because it
first,
it was so visceral and all of this,
everything that it took for him to come
back and put it in and then pull them
down was crazy because tyrone's bong and
him are both super high level.
Kickbox is.
You only really saw that mostly in mma.
I really didn't see it that much.
A high level kickboxing and that's why
we talked there is now.
I mean Matt embry,
this kid from Canada who's now a,
are going to be fighting in Los Angeles
next week.
There's Canada to where the sport is
banned in so many of the provinces.
But Joseph,
valvoline,
he had
to retire because of the concussion
issues.
Um,
place on next week.
Awesome.
He's a smart kid,
man.
He's a great guy.
He,
I don't think he's 100 percent decided
on his retirement,
but he's leaning towards that.
That's either concussions a,
not something you want to.
You want to mess with.
Remember Tj grant?
Yup.
He was exactly.
Benson had the title and a lightweight
division never kept saying never came
back and from concussions I just pumped
up.
Pit Bull.
It was people who broke his shin.
It was in the military.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
That bone in the next two.
We should.
People are.
People love whatever it is.
Yeah.
It's interesting also that like we know
we're talking about kickboxing,
not really gaining ground in America.
Ballot tourism really gain ground either
though,
you know,
it's,
it reaches a certain point in some of
the ratings were really good.
Like when Kim Shamrock,
those freak show,
Meryl Streep or Scott,
there is a promoter.
Always has been,
always will be in.
I mean he,
there's that mix where I think Bella
tour has to focus on because you have to
see for the large part,
98 percent,
99 percent of the best talent,
but Bella toward trying.
But you're right,
and again,
I think it's also because Joel,
we talked about too much of everything
[inaudible] it's every week something.
The UFC did it as well.
At first they got to have to fight us
underneath the fight.
By having so many show,
she shut every hug a organization.
But then you look at guys,
a few guys in Beltour like Lima who just
knocked out course golf,
which is fuck this world class,
terrific fighter.
Martin,
Marla,
I mean world series of fighting.
Even man,
there's Marlon Moraes guide sheet we
talked about,
was it for me?
For me too many times he got lit up to
win that fight.
He won,
but he got hit too many times.
He really needs to stay.
Change his game.
He knows she can take a punch,
but he thinks too much advantage of it
and I just don't think it's that.
What are the goals?
Respect.
Like realistic,
like you say,
like even belt Torres and got traction.
So how do there,
how did they continue to exist?
It is,
it is hard because they've been around
for a long time now.
World series of fighting for a long time
now and the hardcore hardcore fans and
then you break it down,
not even regular heart rate,
hardcore hardcore are watching those
events.
It's almost like we're spoiled.
We have too many and it's weird to say
because how many years did we fight?
Hey,
look at us now.
It's like,
wow,
a tsunami of action.
Well the UFC has been super wise but
it's promotion.
We know how to stay on top and they
know,
but it just,
I would like to see a challenger emerge
and like right now it doesn't,
you know,
there's Beltour has guys like Michael
Chandler,
they've got some guys that are really
exciting and really fun to watch and I
think it'd be genuine stars.
And of course Michael,
a venom for sure,
and sent Cyborg.
Nahko was called crushing it.
Never seen him,
never seen him before.
Is dented in his skull.
It was crazy.
It was crazy timing too because you
know,
cyborg charge down and it was kind of
what we're talking about,
but someone shooting for a double,
but I don't think his knees were on the
ground with that.
No,
but as he shot in Michael Venom page,
timed it perfectly and going down in a
member technori Goldman Health Gracie,
but need burst onto the fight.
That was the hops last.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah,
man.
I mean nice to a guy was trying to take
you down.
It's so devastating.
You,
you,
you have to commit to that knee or
commit to that takedown.
Get caught coming in like that.
Like you could shoot with what he went
in front of your face.
It's very hard.
That was probably the most horrific
injury I've ever seen in MMA.
I think so,
yeah.
Like afterwards,
the pictures,
you know,
with all these little lights on them and
saying he wants to fight again.
He's nobody's retiring.
Just announced.
Yeah.
I think he snapped back after the fact
and we just really realized like,
wow,
the fucking egg that contains my brain
is cracked.
I'm like,
it's amazing that he recovered the way
he did as far as I can.
After seeing the,
the x rays and pictures,
it tuition was fucking insane.
I thought he'd be dead and now you think
some of the skull was crushed like that.
They're dead.
I went to fingers.
That's the touch.
Something of the,
of the brain that does something to you.
Right?
It's a scary thing if you think about
it.
And how much damage did his brain taking
that?
I mean,
that is a significant mgd,
but in his career,
not only,
uh,
Jordan men against him.
One amazing thing that just hit that.
Who was going on?
Oh,
crazy.
How many.
Like you say,
if what to seed Nogueira at his prime
and UFC.
How many wars did old go annual jury go
through it.
But how many shots did they take?
Like full fighter in the garden and Lego
men don't do too many fighters in.
Probably borrowed the.
Again,
what we talked about,
the stomps,
the other Gary Goodrich right now is
coming out.
It's so sad to see you because the guy
was.
It was amazing.
I just saw the was some,
I don't know if it was just one of those
sports.
A news magazine shows the with the NFL
and stuff that they had 99 samples of
former football player's brains were
dedicated.
Out of those,
almost 100 percent showed signs of cte.
Yeah.
I can't imagine you get away without it.
I mean,
it's just,
you're colliding into each other.
It's terrible.
There's no,
there's no way around it.
Nope.
You know,
and if you're,
you know,
Gary Goodrich said that is really his k
one career that did a man may fights the
gatekeeper.
They're all show you much,
but hey,
knocked out tito all the way in the
beginning.
We were talking about it at the pride
fighting championships when he came over
there.
He was a powerful guy,
man.
He'll,
you remember what dodd frank and hope,
a speedy recovery.
The Dawn.
Actually I just texted him yesterday.
Yeah,
I remember when he came back to a pride,
the New Year's eve shown goodridge
knocked out right away to the rivalry.
But yeah,
goodrich was a beast back in the day as
well.
What happened?
He,
he beat Gary Young,
UFC,
UFC of course.
And then in the pride,
the rematch was,
uh,
years later in pride on New Year's Eve.
And it was like one kick,
Gary.
Now was it kickboxer,
you know,
he started training again.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
I forgot them.
I member Friday yama courses,
the plastic so much.
And I felt it immediately forgot about
Friday.
And then I've added it to goodwill
started.
What about Swanson?
And look how many.
I mean,
I'm an amazing tool to account many
shots.
That was a crazy fight.
That was the one of the most chaotic
fights I've ever watched.
And one of the most,
like the data wasn't going in my head
correctly.
I was like,
how is he getting hit with these
haymakers that cubs Swanson's winging in
from downtown Cleveland and cracking him
on his head when he came from across the
country,
punches crazy,
just stagger back and then come crack
him again.
He would stagger back room a room.
Everybody's standing there watching it.
It was insane.
Picked it as the.
There's so many.
That's a thick.
Remember it started with lawler and
conduct for fights.
That was a crazy holloway.
You know,
when you draw the line and then they
started slugging it out.
One of my favorite guys to man,
I went up on this,
that's going to mcgregor too.
Like he's 100 percent convinced he's
going to get a title,
you know,
he's one of these guys that there's
nobody's going to know.
But we went the distance with connor,
but I mean connor did kind of being
blown out of the.
That's right towards later he said that
he was also injured.
Oh,
Max was.
I believe it.
You know,
max is a real.
I mean,
he's an interim champion right now,
but he's world championship caliber.
Oh yeah.
Want to see how he does against all
though.
I want to see how he does.
Again,
some of the best guys,
but know he's finished cups wants.
And should we get rid of interim titles
through and through boxing,
mma all to shit.
Uh,
I think the only way that interim titles
make any sense if someone is recovering
from a catastrophic catastrophic injury.
Yeah.
Like someone blows her acl out and you
go,
okay,
well the title is now going to be
suspended for a whole year.
Yup.
Because it's gonna take six months
before you can even start training again
and then like nine months we can start
training hard and then three months to
go through a camp you need and then
you've got crews took even longer or,
or do you simply say,
listen,
the title is going to be taken away from
you,
you know,
you're not the champion anymore but you
are the first one in line as soon as she
come back.
And that's usually the case a lot of the
time.
Right.
When they do recover they do get the.
But I just think the think.
So I think that's an easy because then
they lose that history books,
right?
Yeah,
that's true.
Makes Sense.
Someone's got a bad injury and you know,
like Anderson Silva made sense with the
owner to take it away.
And uh,
I mean,
I know if he wasn't going to defend it,
but we know,
I mean they,
they needed to.
Again,
I don't think the UFC is the one just
down the hallway when they took it away
from title.
Well,
I know,
but it's not defending the title.
You guys take it away from him.
If all those already the champion,
then the winter of Holloway and walk,
they become the number one contender.
Then the problem is you tie up the
titles.
You got a guy who's the champion champ,
champ.
Like connor champ at 45 and 55.
You got to say you got to vacate one
because it's like to hold two of them
subsequently or then they should've done
it right then and there.
He made history.
Thank you very much.
Was the one title Let.
I'm not going to defend all.
He's got to decide.
You know,
he decided he's going to stay at 55
where they decided not to know what the
fuck's going on,
but I don't think he can get for what if
45.
It's going to be hard for.
Let's see.
There's another way.
Cut that.
You're right.
I don't think we should be at 1:45.
Doesn't look like a man when you see me
at 1:45
or two to cut in in depth.
It's terrible.
You can only do that so many times.
Much healthier at 1:55
and there's a bunch of fights for him.
But then when they were talking about.
No,
no,
no med off fighting.
Turning Tony Ferguson guys.
Yeah.
Look at that fucking picture on the
left.
He looks he looks like a taxi cab.
Yeah.
Much,
much healthier.
Right.
So I think that,
you know,
if they were talking about having,
although and normally when madoff fight
for an interim,
1:55
title or Ferguson was 45,
I think that's.
Well 45 is now,
although all those a champ,
right?
Max Hall was the interim champ.
Those guys have 100 percent,
100 percent.
But now all the.
I mean I don't know if it's true,
but in a normal going out.
So it was bullshit.
They were talking about Aldo fighting a
super fight with Russia and of course
Tony Ferguson's like what?
Well,
Tony Ferguson wanted more money than
this contract stated and unfortunately
for him,
he's in a weird position right now
because there's so many fights to be
made at 55 and the big one of course is
connor.
Sure.
Anybody who conor fights,
if it decides to fight conor and they
decided that's the big fight and they
put her on in Russia anywhere,
but for sure fucking low.
I Irish guys in the Russian guys,
they do realize just how big he is in
Russia,
number combined off giant.
He's a huge star when he,
when he goes on stage too,
like when he steps onto the platform and
enters into the cage,
fucking crowd goes nuts.
They know who he is.
It's just one of those things where the
Russians are way ahead of the game in
terms of knowing who he is.
He's a giant star over there,
but he could be a giant star over here
to kids,
kids of color on the walls.
People and if funny guy to you know,
outside of five has got personality.
I like him.
He's,
you know,
he's a real wild card in that division
because he's undefeated mean we saw one
moment of weakness.
That's it.
One moment was in trouble and he came
back from that brilliantly.
Cain Velasquez again.
Yeah,
he's gonna fight again.
But you know,
he's got some serious fucking medical
problems.
He's got a stenosis,
spinal stenosis,
which is.
They have to clean out his area.
Whereas spine.
So what would you fight again?
Because he's got.
He's got a dream.
You say medically like that.
If it's better,
you don't.
Well apparently the doctors are very
convinced that they can open up that
pathway a little bit and whatever is
pressing down on the bone spurs or
anything that are pressing down the
nerve,
they can remove those and that'll
alleviate as issues.
I don't know that I'm not a doctor.
I don't know.
Poor guy,
man.
He fucked up that he had a.
He had surgery exactly before the fight.
That was a big mistake was because you
put,
you know,
Bob Bennett and the Nevada state
commission in a terrible position
because you're saying that you're
compromised and so then they ran some
tests on him and I guess his doctor
cleared him,
but the Nevada state athletic commission
was like,
look,
you're going to have to have a cortisone
shot,
numb everything up,
and even though you might have some,
you know,
you don't have really a problem as far
as the structure of your back.
You might be compromised.
Something like,
can't do it.
Go get the surgery.
What about that French?
A heavyweight.
And God knew who he was.
Yeah.
He figured it out when you were talking.
I was thinking about him.
I'm like,
wow,
that guy is a.
he's terrifying monster men.
Yeah.
And you know,
it can punch so fucking hard and he
kicks so hard to.
And he gets into the octagon to certain
dudes.
They walk into the octagon.
They sound different like fee.
They're just bigger man.
Gonzaga was Zaga would step on the
platform to weigh in and you just feel
like Jesus,
he's made of stone and it was just
heavier.
I love those elbows.
You remember that he threw so over the
top.
Through the defense on the ground when
he was in the garden.
Yeah.
Well it was blue.
Sweet revenge.
When Marco came back,
smashed him with elbows from the top and
they're crazy.
That fight.
Mirko was saying that one of the things
he doesn't like about the UFC vs pride
was the,
that there's too much grappling and that
there's too many elbows on the ground.
What won them?
The fight.
Grappling and elbows on the ground.
Yeah,
fucking crazy.
He was worried that Zach was just trying
to take him down and that he wasn't
gonna stand with them so he couldn't get
his revenge from the head kick knockout,
but he got while he takes Gonzaga down,
he's on top and he smashes him with
Elvis.
It's unbelievable,
man.
Learn learning game while he realized
that it also,
when you've got a guy who that level
striker,
like Arco is
throwing elbows from the guard.
You see how much force you can generate
where he's retired again after winning
the rise and things.
What a great way.
Great way to go out on an epic Korea.
One of the all time.
Of course,
the whole of the prank you pull,
but I mean the fight will fade or just.
He was one of the.
For me,
the guy right away when you were around
him was like,
Holy Shit,
I'll never forget his stare down with
vandelay for that first fight.
My first fight.
Someone for someone finally out stared
vandelay.
No,
he was another fruit.
No fucking straight up killer can write
into your soul.
Yeah.
Ready to cut your heart out for the
fucking butter knife.
That was no joke,
man.
That that's why it was so easy to set
him up because America didn't want to
interview by anybody.
He wanted me to interview him and nobody
else could interview him,
so that whole respect to state.
He never showed foot a whole press
conferences.
He hated the media media just because.
Well there were a member of the
translation.
He,
I guess there was an interview right
with our member.
There was an interview where I guess the
pride people were translating a wrong
and he came across these like a few
guys.
So your boss had a kitchen.
But uh,
yeah,
I was very intimidated.
My man and uh,
he got me good.
But he a wow.
But it showed a personality too because
that was the time where it.
So when he came he became your buddy.
I don't know what the fuck you're
talking about.
He played a prank on morrow.
Okay,
well the,
the,
the prank was this,
uh,
he was facing miracle quote was facing
Ron Waterman.
Now the way we set it up like two days
before the fight,
we both interviewed with fighter.
He fought interviews,
waterman.
I interviewed because she never wanted
to do anything with kroger.
He was afraid of kroger upset.
He wasn't one to be interviewed by me.
So I'm already before this,
I'm thinking,
okay,
I gotta do some shit.
I went to Croak up and I said,
listen,
I'm going to interview Waterman.
And then it's like,
oh no,
hell no.
Mom.
But you're going to have to interview a
miracle.
Are you okay with that?
He said sure.
So He.
Because he thought it was funny.
So one of them comes in.
I started interviewing him and sure
enough when he left,
I look at Morrow,
I go,
oh dude,
I'm so sorry.
And he goes,
what?
I said,
I interviewed a waterman.
So I said,
well,
you're going to have to do an interview.
He goes,
no man,
I don't want to interview America.
You know,
it's just a miracle.
I never wanted to go to these
interviews.
He wants to be interviewed on the day of
the event in his dressing room.
So we go to the dressing room with him
and he starts and a miracle is now all
in on it and at this moment.
And he starts telling you,
hey,
you know,
want in Waterman?
He said something about a funeral and
miracle,
his thinking.
He said he'd come back and he says,
a funeral list.
When somebody passes away and America
goes,
I know what a funeral this.
So it starts like that.
And slowly but surely and Sunday miraco
stops and he says,
you know,
I didn't in my life the way you were
commentating on my fight the last time.
And it wasn't him compensated with
somebody else.
So he goes,
no,
it wasn't me.
No,
no,
it was you.
They looked at his corner and the
quarter to go shoot.
And he's looking at me tomorrow.
Looks at me like a little help,
a little help.
But I'm just looking away,
you know,
I'm not saying anything.
And then yeah,
no,
I really didn't expect no,
but I really wasn't doing it.
But give it back.
Go back to the question.
So we stopped.
But now miracle start getting annoyed,
you know,
and he doesn't want to ask questions
anymore.
He says,
do it,
this guy segment,
he doesn't like me,
I don't want to scare.
So he gets out that we send him back.
And we said,
no,
you've got to have to ask him a few more
questions.
So we know he's going back and he sits
down again and he starts going and
miracles.
Suddenly vehicle gets up,
says,
you know what,
this is it,
and he walked straight up tomorrow and
Morris stop pissing his pants.
Of course things are.
This is over and moral comes out and
says,
no,
no.
Okay.
I don't want to.
Do you need one more question?
We need one more question because no,
I don't want to like a few guys.
And I go,
Oh,
a miracle cream out of the dressing
room.
And he started walking straight up to
Norway.
Morris,
you seem shrinking.
And he goes,
do it is all just a joke.
It was a miracle coming down.
He's gonna fucking left.
Kicked my head off,
my career's done.
I'm finished.
And then he,
he was in on it,
buddy.
Yeah,
you guys.
It was a terrifying.
Well that was when he was ahead of the
antiterrorist Croatia shit.
Yeah.
No,
he did.
He had some hits,
some little notches on his life,
like big Rambo next.
It was some real shit.
You never want it to.
You never came to the press conferences
showed up to fight and got the hell out
of dodge.
Well,
he was one of the first real high level
kickboxers to enter into Brian.
Once he learned how to sprawl,
started lightened up like champion.
Remember that knocked out fate or his
brother vandelay.
The open way to Grand Prix was heavier
than vandelay,
was to 18 to 14 federal aid.
Mark Hunt with randy couture,
a commentary.
There's a small country over his right
eye or put the atomic weight.
A lot of people thought that that fight
kind of ruined.
Vandelay hunt cracked him a couple of
times and I'm stunned in that fight and
that was one of one of vandelays last
fights in his prime,
but he's another one man,
right?
Come money.
Just him and Quinton Rampage Jackson.
How about that for a dramatic Kao,
a Halloween I probably 28 when Jackson
did very well in the rematch and then go
vandelay catches them again.
The nice in between the ropes and he
went,
holy crap.
That was a bad knockout.
He smashes,
knows what's going on with Randall
Randall,
who's going to fight and rise.
And I heard what he was supposed to
fight,
bug Miraco in the rising thing and he
didn't.
He pulled out.
He had an injury or something.
I don't know.
You were hanging out with Bellatore and
another one.
Man,
I can't fight anymore,
man.
I'm not the one that say by any means.
But what's the point?
Definitely can fight camp.
Fight.
Yeah.
But not his.
He's his health is good.
I mean that's it in a long time now too.
You've got to think like this is a long
time off.
Yeah.
I remember once he told us in pride,
he dog.
I go,
how long,
you know,
typical question.
How much longer you want to do?
Well,
randy couture did it until he was 48,
so I'm going to do it until I'm 50.
Well,
what do you guys think about what
happened with vandelay?
Because with vandelay they came to him,
saw came to him,
they tried to test him and he's like,
I'm Outta here.
You fucking brain did the same thing.
Remember?
He flew back to Holland.
Yep.
When was this member?
He was a war against me.
Or was it.
Or what the fight was supposed to be
where he was the same thing,
kind of got out of dodge when testing
was looking for him.
But vandelay same.
Yeah.
I didn't know about the house.
What it is.
Yeah.
He uh,
what was the first alice stroke first
they went to.
Same thing,
but he tried to say,
well,
I didn't know that you guys were a
sprints away from drugs.
Okay.
So this is 2012.
That was back when it was a real,
like a real.
This is really rare that you will get
caught.
Ya,
Ya see,
break the mirror right there.
So yeah,
I mean it's done right.
It's definitely not gun.
I'm guilty.
Yup.
Yeah.
But it just seems like to me,
they railroaded him.
I mean,
you can't just take the guy's career
away,
you know,
if you tested him and he was positive,
that's whatever punishment he,
if he runs away from the test,
just stays positive.
And then he would have already been
fighting again.
Yeah.
You know.
But instead they tried to sustain that
forever.
Forever.
Forever for life.
So he got that overturned,
but now he's still battling out in court
who knows how much it cost him in court,
but didn't do himself any favors.
But with this interview,
you know,
bashing UFC batch and everybody was
worse than that.
I started making youtube videos.
Right.
Took a mania staring in front of the
camera.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It just got crazy.
I mean it was probably some really dark
moments for him.
Oh,
I bet.
I mean,
where's he make money now?
Just as Jim,
I guess.
Right?
Backed.
I don't even know what was taught as a
fighter for me.
It's hard to not do it anymore to.
Oh and especially not train anyway so
that she can at least when you can
train.
Right.
But did the feeling.
There's no feeling like it to walk out
that hey,
you know,
are you training at all anymore?
No.
One just water exercise on the water and
uh,
and sometimes had to do with weights
trading.
My just my right arm.
Pretty much works.
You're going to fight federally and
pride with dynamite show.
That was official.
That was good.
I was facing to fight him to ask me,
you want to fight,
but identified for a long time and I
said,
listen,
I'd only been striking.
So since this is a mix between k one and
and pride,
why don't we do a kickboxing match,
but the gloves,
I would love to do that and then.
But they didn't go for it.
He,
he chose another opponent at the time.
So.
But that.
I think that would have been such a
change for you.
What would it be?
Cool.
That's good money at the time.
That would have been a crazy fight.
What's holding?
What's holding you back from becoming
like pride again?
Superstar.
A superstar superstar and just they just
need some big Japanese dude to come
along.
There's some sacral Robert type
character to capture the public's never
brushed of suck Arab guy,
man.
I mean he took some horrible mess when
he fought Hanzo again and the metamorris
Kelly and frank and I had a chance to
visit with them.
Frank was very close to fighting soccer.
Robin Pride.
They offered a,
a big contract.
Same thing.
They couldn't come to an agreement but
a,
well,
listen,
we've got to wrap this up,
but you guys were a duo for some of the
greatest fights of all time,
you know,
and I,
I enjoyed it deeply enjoyed it and I
appreciate you guys coming on joining
this a lot and let everybody know about
your podcast.
You got two podcasts going on.
We dropped a one on Monday,
combat sports carousel where we cover
mma,
boxing a little wwe and kickboxing as
well,
and a boss breaks it down like a Boston.
Then on Fridays it's just Boston.
I riffing on a bunch of different things
on life,
movies,
entertainment,
comedy rooted in Rainelle,
Rutan and Rainelle.
If you spelled out all and whichever
Nela.com,
you can find all the oldest and
soundcloud and the other one is combat
sports carousel.
You can find it.
Once you click on the link,
you'll see them all.
All right.
Thank you gentlemen.
Thank you.
Bye.